The cord to Sir.
Hi everybody.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on
the link for flashlight and enter in the
code name Brogan, you will get 15%
off the number one sex toy for men.
It's the number one cause. It's awesome.
It feels wicked good on your penis.
With that said, my pal Duncan
trussell's here, buckle up bitches.
Here we go. Better late than
never going to experience my girls
with such a long absence of two weeks
off the podcast. Ladies and gentlemen,
you were Jones and I was Jones and we
had to bring you back the three most
pertinent guests in the same week. Joe
Diaz, Ari Shaffir and they'll finally,
Duncan Trussell my favorite
buddy. Hi, I'm, I'm,
I'm psyched to have you on for a whole
bunch of reasons because there's a bunch
of nutty shit that's been going down
that we must discuss. All right.
Did you hear about the Cork Glue on a
particle that the large Hadron collider
has created? No. Oh,
this is fantastic stuff.
We talked about it yesterday or
Monday or yesterday. Okay. Yesterday,
one sugar tube of this shit
weighs 40 billion pounds. Wow.
It's more dense than a neutron star.
It's like the singer,
single densest piece of matter
that that theoretically is,
is physically possible and
they created it. What w
they created it and what happened exactly
as it go through the ground and the
fucking, who knows? You have a marble,
you drop the marble and the ground.
It shoots right through China,
comes out an exit wound like Kennedy's
head and then it goes back down and goes,
it's like a nonstop thing. You like
gravity, you know what you mean?
Comes up and down through the
earth. The earth, I think I own, hi.
What the fuck does, I think I
heard something. Not about this,
but the possibility of this and how that
could be one of the possible extinction
events is that it sets off a chain
reaction and sucks everything in. Yeah.
Oh my God. Well, if you think
about the idea of that this,
this cork glue on thing, the idea
that they can create this, you know,
this is the bottom line about all this
shit is it's never going to stop right
there.
No way they're going to keep going and
if they can create something that's this
heavy,
what if they created enough of it?
We're really is like something that
goes through the fucking earth.
If you had something that was
so heavy that it would like,
you would drop it and it would just
shoot down through the earth. Yeah.
Where would it stop? It
wouldn't, would it? I don't know.
I mean if it's so heavy that it smashes
rock and then when it hits the core,
what happens?
Does the core melted?
Is it it? Maybe it gets melted in
the core. It makes a volcano. Yeah.
What does it make a new volcano?
I mean,
does it matter how big this cork gluon
plasma? We're talking probably a tiny,
tiny thing. Yeah. It's
nothing like a micro meteorite
or something. Yeah, it's, it's the,
the crazy thing is these guys
that are doing this stuff,
they all know that this is crazy
and they're joking around about it.
So there's some photos now
of them playing half life.
If you just look up large Hadron collider
is guys get theater theatrical with
halflife street theater.
There's them, he's got, uh,
the orange safety helmet on just like the
half life of character with a crow bar.
And the other guys got like a head
crab on. Have you seen it? You seen it?
I just opened it. It's hilarious. They
know what the fuck they're doing. I mean,
I guess they just,
you just have to keep doing it,
but they're aware of it and all
the while there's this wall,
this all comes out.
This is a cosmologists have
reconciled this a seemingly impossible
contradiction. The contradiction of the
super position. Contradiction, you know,
the super position is that something can
exist and not exist at the same time.
And there's two different,
there's,
there's the multiverse theory and
there's the many worlds theory.
And apparently they figured out some
way to reconcile these two theories.
It's so hard to fucking understand.
It's like,
it's so difficult to wrap my
brain around, you know, I'm,
I'm just not really smart enough or
have enough experience with this kind of
shit. But, you know, the observability
of the universe, it's like,
it's when you get down to a quantum
particles, when you get down to, you know,
subatomic particles,
it gets really weird.
It's a hard to understand
how this can be real,
that something can appear and disappear
and no one knows where it went.
And they can also appear in both, in two
different positions at the same time.
And it's the same particle.
Isn't there also something where
apparently your expectation of the thing
somehow impacts it? The viewer, they
don't understand that either. You know,
there's, it's really hard for me to
explain it without butchering it,
but you can look up Dr Quantum,
you know, there's some,
some videos of it online where it's
explained in cartoons for complete retards
like you and I, and it's
basically they, you know,
they shoot these particles and there's
a different reaction when people are
watching then when people aren't
watching, you know, and uh,
the idea that something is
in a superposition basically
means it could be in
motion and it can be
still at the same time.
It's like the way they describe it as the,
it's like you cannot see a dead cat and
a live cat that have the same cat at the
same time.
You know?
And the idea that a lot of people
believe is that every single possibility
happens for every single it.
Like say you open up a door,
every fucking possible thing
happens once you open up that door.
Infinite possibilities,
but not to you, to you.
One thing happens and you live in this
one dimension. And in this one dimension,
this one thing happens.
And for everyone else,
you know,
or all these other use that exist in an
infinite number of different universes.
You don't experience that,
but it happens. That's why goals are so
important because when you have a goal,
you're setting something in the future,
which is,
if you think about things in
the way you just described it,
what you're really thinking about is in
this great array of possibilities in the
future,
there's one node that contains within
it all the different possibilities that
involve whatever your goal happens to be.
And so the goal becomes literally a kind
of compass that's guiding you toward
this place and temporal spatiality
where these things that you want to have
happen happen. That's what everybody
says. If you want to be successful,
have a goal, and you know when I
want, before I knew about this,
I used to think that meant yes,
because it will give me the discipline
in the motivation to work towards what I
want.
But metaphysically you may actually be
sort of guiding the ship of your life
towards this temporal possibility and
then getting the things that you want.
It's a lot of
right. But there's also the problem of
the cynic in the cynic point of view,
which, you know, Penn and teller or
big cynics on that bullshit show.
And I really liked Penn Jillette.
He's a very fun guy. And uh,
one of the things that he really nailed
is all these assholes that pitch the
secret and you try and tell people with
horrible terminal diseases that it's
their fault. But that shit is
ridiculous because it is not absolute.
It does not work in all circumstances.
And little babies are not responsible
for getting hit by bullets and drive bys.
Cause that shit does happen. So it
is not, it's not clean, you know?
Oh No, it's not clean. But if you
want to get really weird, if you,
if we're talking about
this idea that you're,
your perception and faith
guide you into the different,
all the different universes that exist,
then Penn and teller,
there's such skeptical assholes that
maybe they've guided themselves into a
universe of absolute boring bullshit.
Those guys just want to live in a world
of like, you know, what's it called?
Newtonian physics where everything comes
from an accident and all that stuff.
It's the religion that's
the religion of the day.
So you're,
what you're saying is that because
they've refused to believe in any psychic
phenomenon,
they refuse to believe in anything
trippy or woo woo that they're,
they live in a limited world.
Penn and teller should know
my mom got bone cancer.
My mom went to a faith
healer. My, my mom, uh,
her bone cancer is now like almost gone.
You tell me.
We did the faith healer do it.
Was it her faith that did it?
It's fucking bone cancer.
Masta ties breast cancer into our bones,
her tumor markers.
That's how they measure bone cancer or
less than when she went in and got the
original diagnosis. So it's
reversing, it's going backwards now.
He went to a faith healer. I'm not a liar.
I don't, you know what I mean? I'm not, I,
I'm not making this shit up, dude. Do
I think it could be other things? Sure.
Probably a combination of everything.
But that was on medication as well. Yeah,
she was. She was, she was,
and she also cut sugar out and there's
a lot of different things that she did,
but one component of it was
this event that she went to.
Now do I believe in faith
healers? Nah, no, I don't.
But I do believe that if somebody can
create the illusion in the mind of a
person,
some kind of event,
to give them the faith to believe
that they can heal themselves,
then maybe that works. The
mind controls that. I mean,
think about it. Your body is,
when cancer happens in your DNA starts
fucking up. That's part of your body.
That's you, yourselves. Are
you, your neurons are you?
It's all you to think that
you can't control that.
The thing that some deeper part of
you can't control that. It's crazy.
Of course you could.
Is it that or is it that this faith healer
puts her on this incredibly positive
vibration and because of the fact that
he thinks that this woman or this was it
a woman or she thinks she
was a woman or as a man,
my mom was your mom a metal?
Are you saying?
I never checked.
You don't know if the faith healer
or as a man or a woman of faith,
you are as a man. His name's John
of God. Well, maybe your mom,
because of the fact that she so
believes and so needs this to happen.
She goes and maybe all the sudden she
has this incredible feeling of positive
expectations and instead of doom and
gloom and that's enough to turn things
around. That's it. That's what I did.
Then she's also on medication too, dude,
you gotta you have to, the idea is it's
like you're not medication. You know?
I don't know.
Bone Marrow River where
you're, you're, you're in a way your
phone away. That's not what you want.
You want bone come back. You're,
you're, you're not just your mind.
You're not just your body.
So it's like,
I think you'd have to
address the problem with,
well you are just your mind and your body,
but it's all one unit.
You are,
you want to address each piece,
each piece of the puzzle,
like give your mind something to work on.
Your mind is dealing with the horror of
riding around in a car that's breaking
down and it will soon turn into warm food.
That sucks when you have a western
doctor being like, well, you know,
statistically, which the
doctor did say to my mom, uh,
she had six months to live and that
was like over a year ago. Uh, the,
the doctor, when your, when
your mind hears that, it's
not like, ah, you know what?
I'm going to really start healing
now. You're just like, fuck,
I'm dead meat. I'm about to go on to
infinity. And so then they're like,
we understand that you're
feeling depression,
so we're going to prescribe
some antidepressants to
you to help you deal with
the sorrow of your own demise.
Now you're fucking with
your brain in the wrong way.
You're messing it up with antidepressant.
They do when people are diagnosed
with terminal cancer that give them
antidepressants, Pallium, Xanax,
calm down the anxiety or just going
to relax you and do infinity. Whoa.
That sounds like a good move though.
If you're fucked up on ease your mind
bone cancer. Yeah, no. If it's a wrap,
it's a wrap. Right. And when it's
going to be a wrath eventually for all,
what would it be better to go
out? No, that's the problem man.
Especially with the problem
with cancer is that, um,
we've heard so much stuff about
it that you hear, you know,
the cancer diagnosis for a lot of people,
you're like, I'm dead. Right. But, um,
one of the other things that my mom did,
and there's some great books out there
that are, uh, basically say that,
uh,
cancer loves sugar.
So if you're fucking drinking
a lot of sugar sugary stuff,
then the tumors will grow faster.
So somehow cancer doesn't do that well.
And then an acidic environment.
So if you start drinking alkaline,
alkaline, alkaline. Yeah.
So it's something like drinking lemon
juice and all this stuff. Healthy
for a lot of Greens, a lot of, uh, yeah.
Well that's really what's best for the
body. You have to know where our bodies,
I mean, the Paleo Diet is one
that's really popular right now.
And the idea is that, you know, during
the caveman days, what do they eat?
They eat vegetables that were edible
and they eat meat. Yeah. You know,
and that's really what
you're supposed to be eating.
You're not supposed to be eating any
pastas or grains or anything funky, right.
Anything that people created and
you know, no soups. Gluten. Yeah.
You're supposed to eat pasta and I mean,
you're supposed to eat meat and grain
or meat and vegetables. Yeah. No Pasta,
no grains, nothing human created. And
just think of yourself as like, you know,
a person living in that era. You know,
really that's the healthiest way to live,
man. You know, the healthiest way to
live is to get a lot of vegetables,
a lot of like Broccoli and
anything with like, you know,
with fiber that's going to clean
out your colon vitamins. You know,
Brock Lesnar had to go
in for a colon surgery.
He had diver diverticulitis that
you get from eating too much meat.
It's a disease that you get from
literally not having vegetables and it's a
terrible one where your guts rot out.
It's really scary shit.
Can I tell you guys something
that's really embarrassing
that has to do with uh,
in tennis.
[inaudible] um,
this sounds so stupid and someone
sent me this video as a joke,
which is this guy showing how
to shit what? Yeah, the Western,
I was using one of those platforms that
you put over the toilet feed up on this
platform. Yeah. Cause that's the healthy
way to squat. Did this technique,
and I have to tell you,
I am shitting like a 10 year old.
It's the craziest fucking thing ever.
Possibly even mean you shouldn't,
we haven't brought you shooting before.
Where you having promised shitting before
w no, not having problems shitting,
but it's like, you know like people,
Americans will sit on the toilet and read.
Right, right. I'm going to read a book.
It's like shitting is not supposed to
take that lock. Yeah. Look at your dog.
How long does it take your dog to shit.
If your dog takes longer than like a
minute to shit, your automatic like,
oh something's wrong.
Something's wrong with the dog food.
That's exactly right.
And that's why you're a scientist.
No Man. I, the problem is, is
like joy it though it's more of a,
I enjoy the whole process. I could
squirt it out real quick if I want it to,
but I enjoy it feels good.
Joy having turds. Yes.
You don't enjoy taking a nice shit.
Hmm.
Do you? I love it. I love it to him. I'm
going to say his favorite activities,
especially when I eat a lot of lettuce
and it just comes on nice and loose shows.
Ah, yeah. But it's not
something I look forward to.
I like the little plop splash
that plops back and I'm like,
gives you a little kiss on your butt
hole from little piece of water.
You don't look forward to it.
Like when you're coming home,
you're entered into the
door and you're like,
I am going to take a giant shit right now.
You don't look forward to that.
Well now of course. I mean I wouldn't,
looking forward to it. It's like a weird,
like I, I look forward to it. The walking
dead, the second season coming out.
That's, I look forward to you
don't look forward to a shit.
Okay.
It's not, I mean, yeah. Okay, fine.
I look forward to it, but it's not,
it doesn't take up my time.
I'm not like,
I'm not listening to love songs on my
radio therapist about potty over there.
I know how many times a day do your shit.
I shit once a day.
All right. Wow. That's it.
So you're not enjoying Coby this crazy
fucking African African you to change
your diet.
You're supposed to shit twice a day
should all three times a day probably.
If you eat a lot more, you're
supposed to, first of all,
you're supposed to eat several meals a
day and that's supposed to be just one or
two meals a day,
right?
If you want to be lean and
healthy and have a lot of energy,
the key is to not having your body in
a constant state of digestion, right?
So your body is wanting to
adjusting minimal amounts,
not some big fucking giant gorging meal
that just rent your whole system. Well,
if you do that,
what's that stuff going to do?
It's going to sit inside you and wait
for the one big evacuation event at the
end of the night. No, it's going to shit
throughout the day. It's going to be done,
was going to push it out.
Gotcha.
So, um, have you, because of your mom's
situation, have you changed your diet?
Any of you started getting like
conscious about what you eat?
Uh, you know, not because of my
mom's situation weirdly, but, um, I,
I did start taking vitamins a and,
and I've started taking this
stuff called fanning and Relora,
which lowers the,
uh,
there's a chemical in your
body associated with stress.
It gets released by your
adrenal gland and it has some,
apparently lowers the amount of that
stuff in your body. What's it called? Uh,
one of the pills is called
[inaudible] and I guess t, h, e,
t, h, e, n, and the other stuff is
called rural Laura. And one's like this.
It's one of them's like more
relaxing than the other.
You take it at night and the
other one is just a it like,
I don't know if you'd call it a no.
Tropic new tropic. How do you say it?
Nootropic yeah, new tropics. It
does say on the thing, you know,
helps focus and I have to agree.
It really does
wait to try this new tropic formula that
we've, we've come out with. We're a,
we're finalizing it and they'd just
finished the formula that this guy,
Chris Markus, have you tried any
of it? You've been trying it.
I'm done with my supply. This, this
shit gives you the most fucked up,
vivid dreams ever. I'm going to get
you some last night. Here's my dream.
My, the House that I grew up in,
Arnold Schwarzenegger lives in it,
but it's not the house I grew up in.
It's some weird house that's on the
rocks right in front of water that
apparently is semi public.
So Arnold Schwarzenegger is living
there now and he's like swimming around.
But all these people are staring at him
because of his situation and because of
the scandal. But he doesn't give a
fuck. Not only is he not give a fuck,
but he's in really good
shape now in my dream.
And he keeps wanting to pull his balls
out and now he's, he pull his balls out,
but he puts his little bikini
underwear on, like, you
know, like a Frenchman would,
where I was like,
and he pulls his ball somehow or another
through the back of his underwear and
there where his ass cheeks
are and they're giant.
These giant balls that he has hanging
outside of his underwear by his ass hall.
Somehow or another, they're that
big. And you know, he's an old man,
but he looks spectacular and he moves
like with confidence and grace and dives
into the water. And I'm like, I gotta
get my wife away from this motherfucker.
I'm looking at this old crazy man,
like he's just going to fuck every
woman within a, um, a mile radius.
And it's like, he has
no, no inhibitions, no,
no worries about it.
And all these people were watching him
and there's a family that's sitting
behind this rock and they're
like, you know, there's,
they're sitting there watching
Arnold moving around swimming.
He keeps taking his pants off.
He keeps taking his bikini bottoms
off and like washing. And what shop,
whatever it is. It's some crazy,
well, I don't know what it mean.
Freud would have a fucking
field day with this chair.
Like what is this dream
supposed to represent? Well,
terrified of Arnold Swartz.
And I would love to have seen your face
while dreaming and just like the little
flinches and your face with it,
whether they were filings or fear.
Yeah. Well you have to look at
it like this. Uh, they say, uh,
one way to analyze dreams as you look
at every part of a dream is a projection
of some aspect of your life. So Arnold
Schwarzenegger, isn't that your id?
Isn't that your lower primal self? Some
kind of like that. That would be that the,
the dry, the sex drive,
the like the drive,
the power drive. So you're kind of
vanity drive. He's a bodybuilder.
That's like the most vain thing you could
possibly do. And then the public ocean,
you could say, well the
public ocean, that's your, um,
is that your public life is that you're
doing the podcast and you kind of like
have all your shit in front of everyone
on the planet and so you're seeing like
a projection of your ed swimming
through are reacting to like,
I think I'm thinking about
all sorts of negritude. Yeah,
we talked about yesterday.
I don't think it's me.
I don't think that represents me. I see
where you're going with that. But no,
because what this represents to me now,
when I found out that he fucked his maid
and they shot Lowe's and it was made in
that apparently he was doing it for a
long time. What he represents to me,
it's like this almost like unbridled
hedonist that regardless of the stakes of,
you know, of whatever fucked
up thing that he does sexually.
You now he's the governor,
he's a giant movie star,
multimillionaire married to a Kennedy,
basically Shriver's she's some sort of
a Kennedy right in into this respectable
family,
but yet banging maids fucking all
sorts of checks all over the planet.
I'm sure he just never pulled
it back, you know? And that's,
that to me is amazing. There's
something about it in, in my dream,
he was just completely without,
without remorse.
When in my dream he was owning it and
my dream, he was, you know, this is me.
I'm this crazy freak. I'm out here.
I bathe, I UC my balls, you know?
I mean, that was who he was. In my dream,
we've smiling and laughing and waving
to people and he didn't give a fuck,
you know, but in real life, I mean the
poor guy is falling apart and real life.
He's a 60 year old man, kicked out of his
house, you know, and his family knows, he,
he, you know, he had a child the
literally two weeks apart from the,
his own child with the maid, the maid
that was there made for 20 fucking years.
You think will survive all this. I know
you will. No, no, that's a wrap. Yeah.
You think like, if you made a
termino fought fire right now,
Don people are done with him.
How could he do this, this, this,
this is what I think. I mean, it's
possible. Anything can happen.
I might be just talking out of my ass.
I'm the first one to say I'm amazed
at some of the people that have made
comebacks. You know, we'll look at Bill
Clinton. Bill Clinton's a respectable,
you know, former president
now, dude, I remember when I
was, it was during the 90s.
Well, we were working on news radio and
the Monica Lewinsky scandal went town. Uh,
Bill Clinton, man, dude,
they, hey, you need him.
If you listened to Republican radio,
which I used to listen to all the time,
there are people that wanted him dead.
They thought that he
represented everything foul
about the world and the fact
that they caught him getting head from
some 20 year old girl and then lying
about it. And then they drag him. I
mean, they impeached him. You know,
people think impeach means kicked out
of office. It's not what it means.
Would impeach means you,
you bring someone in to decide whether
or not you're kicking them out of office.
And that's what they did with him. Man,
they sat him down and he had to say,
that is not my recollection of
the war. You know, that's not,
what is the word? You know? He's talking
about the word, you know, sex. The,
I didn't, I did not have sexual relations
as I took it to mean sexual relations,
you know, and they can't even say,
what the fuck are you saying, man?
It's the worst man.
Wait,
when whenever I really start feeling
like we live in an advanced civilization
and what really, I had a hard
time and we're really doing it.
Then I hear about this sexually
repressed bullshit where like, so what?
Swartz and Agar, God, his fucking
made pregnant Clinton got a blow job.
Who Cares?
Meanwhile,
George Bush is fucking dropping bombs
on Iraqi babies and everybody's like,
it's fine. He's a great
president. He's killing humans.
Well,
I liked it out.
The Obama's doing it in the liberals
aren't saying a fucking boy.
Isn't that the greatest
hypocrisy of all time? Amazing.
Somehow because Obama's dropping
bombs on Libya, it's okay.
All those democratic actors that love
to talk during table readings and where
Obama pins, you can all go suck my dick
or stupid you guys. You're all dumb.
You all got sucked into a system and he's
done a lot of other great stuff. Yeah,
he's, he is the same thing as Bush.
He's just showing them. Yeah. You know,
Georgia Bill Mar,
which is what I thought you were talking
when we have a conversation before
podcasts.
We talked about it yesterday,
how Bill Maher had this really brilliant
point about how he calls himself a
Christian and yet when they were asking
him about Osama bin Laden's death,
he was like,
anybody who questions whether or not
that's good should have their mind,
their head checked, you know, like,
which is nothing like Christianity's
nothing like Christian doctrine.
There hasn't been a Christian
president for a long,
I'd like a Christian president. I'd
love to see. That would be a real one.
It'd be a real one. Would be Ron Paul.
Yes. Ron Paul has a legit Christian.
He's so legitimate. He doesn't even
believe in evolution. You Know Ron Paul,
thanks. Scott says, well,
he's not stupid, man. Look,
he's got some wacky ass fucking ideas,
but he, he believes in creationism,
you know,
and look,
life itself is fucking beyond
bizarre. All right. I'm,
I'm not ruling out the
possibility of creationism,
but when you start
talking about evolution,
just being a theory and you don't
necessarily agree with that theory,
like you're in Wacko Ville. Like evolution
is not just a theory, it's provable.
There's like there's
transitionary fossils, there's,
there's thousands of scientists
for hundreds of years
have been collecting data
and they can show natural adaptation.
They can show change,
they can show things in our lifetime.
We could show about humans,
especially like men in
Tibet that have gone, uh,
that live at very high altitudes and their
bodies have changed and evolved to be
very different from our bodies.
Yeah. And they've done this to,
to adapt to this really harsh new
environment. It's just what happens man,
if you read the trial
ogs, yes. The Mckenna.
Yeah. Rupert Sheldrake. Yeah. When they
start talking about the morphogenic field.
Yeah. So that like the idea is that
like, and, and so the evolution,
like their idea of evolution, they, they,
they asked this really awesome question,
which is like, you have Newtonian
physics, the laws of the universe,
how the universe works.
And some people apparently think that
these laws of the universe are eternal
laws never changing. They don't
evolve. Everything else is evolving,
but the laws of the
universe stay the same.
And so the awesome question they ask
is, well, okay, where, where did,
where did these laws exist before
the big bank? What did they exist in?
Some kind of bizarre field that it's like,
you know,
the Mckenna has some awesome name, 40 puts
hyper, he attaches hyper to everything.
So I'm kind of like hyperspace
she all platonic field, but like,
where do they exist? Do they
exist there? So they're awesome.
Crazy idea is this thing called a super
attractor that exist in the future,
which is like this perfect form.
This like the mckinna freely uses the
word God because he's not afraid to use
words to like, you know, put
handles on things. But, uh,
it's this idea of this super
perfection that exists in the future.
Kind of like the ultimate goal.
Like what we're talking about.
And it's so powerful.
It's trends in dental object at the end
of time and it's pulling us towards it.
And so evolution is literally is us
being drawn into a relationship with this
perfect form and shifting to become it,
to like transform into it.
And that's what the, the force of
evolution has now. You know, creationism,
it's almost the reverse of
creationism or something.
It's like the creator instead of
existing at the beginning of time,
blasting out everything is somehow
sitting at the end of time,
sucking everything into itself,
which is
pretty cool. Yeah. Well,
there's a law or, or,
or rule or an ethic to
the universe and that's a,
things keep getting more and more complex.
Things don't seem to simplify, right?
Nothing in our lifetime does at least
nothing that we can observe over the
course of the life of the earth does
from the earth cooling to earth,
developing single cell
organisms to multicell organisms
and flowering plant life
after the, you know, the
Yucatan crater after the, the,
the big explosion that
killed the dinosaurs.
I mean everything just keeps getting more
and more and more and more complex to
the invention of course,
of electronics.
And that's where things have gotten
really particularly bizarre because if you
look at life and you look at electronics
and you know you were objective,
you are not a human being,
you are not a carbon based life form.
You were just something without form
that objectifies or disseminates
information. Something that looks at all
the, the data and comes to a conclusion.
Well if you looked at the human life on
this planet and then you looked at the
life of technology, man, um,
I know technology doesn't have cells
and I know technology doesn't have
fingernails and shit like that, but God
dammit, isn't it growing with us? It,
isn't it evolving with us and are there
dead ones that are just laying around
just like old fossils and bodies at apple,
two computer that you have sitting in
your fucking garage and we turn on,
it doesn't really work anymore,
but you still keep it.
That's like your grandma's body.
You know, that's a dead body man.
And we have a symbiotic relationship
with this stuff now. Whereas, you know,
like I've talked about this many times,
I leave the fucking house
without my phone. I'm scared.
I am a lost in the world.
I am such a little bitch. I can't drive
in my car without my phone. And I'm like,
what do I have to goals and money?
I,
I'm terrified that I don't know
anybody's phone number anymore.
I know like four or five people's
phone numbers. Right. You know?
So if I went to a payphone when
goodluck fucking finding one,
are there any payphones anywhere?
I would have to go to like a seven
11 and buy one of those rechargeable,
you know, those are reusable
phones. Yeah. Murder phones. Those,
one of those a fair
phones. And, and you know,
and try to like figure out how
to call people. They're fun.
Well that's what I was thinking
they use them for. Right.
I always feel like they use
them for crime and for affairs.
Yeah. Um, have you seen uh, the
transcendent man? Yes. You saw that? Yeah.
Which is incredible. Amazing.
What is it? It's cursed
well, uh, is a, uh,
they call them a futurist and he's
responsible for many, many patents.
He's a brilliant,
brilliant man and um,
he is a huge proponent of the idea
of the technological singularity.
And the idea behind that is that one
day artificial intelligence is going to
literally and virtually come alive and
we're going to merge with it somehow.
We are either going to be downloaded into
computers or consciousness is going to
be replicated and indistinguishable from
our current consciousness and that will
be downloaded into computers and
though our biological body will die,
are RF electronic signal,
that is our consciousness that has
been recreated. Like, you know,
like you copy a Microsoft word
file. Yeah. You will copy your mind.
You will copy your consciousness,
your soul. Yeah. Yeah.
You will copy something and
you will put it into this,
whatever the fuck it is
that holds all this stuff.
But what we're saying is that life is
almost completely connected to technology
and it's a very, very short time
that this has happened 200 years ago.
There were no cars,
you know,
so in those 200 years we have been
connected to cars who was, um,
a really fascinating video that someone
sent me that I put up on Twitter.
I retweeted it the other day.
You can find it if you just scour
through my Twitter, but it's a,
a time lapse video of,
uh,
of cars moving back and forth on freeways
and how it looks like blood and the
car. Yeah. How it looks like the
pulsating of blood coming back and forth,
you know,
I mean it's,
that clearly is the breath of breathing
in and breathing out the, you know,
the heartbeats in and out the cars, leave
the house and come back to the house.
I mean, it really is. It really is like,
that's crazy. It's a type of life form.
It's just, it happens so slowly. All
this traffic sucks my Dick, you know,
on the fucking my car is dying,
shit and all these things that you,
you micro manage that,
that scenario and then you don't see
it as this pulsating thing of of cars
coming in and cars going out and how
many of them go in the same God damn
direction? Yeah, every
day. Here's the thing,
man, and this is where the,
I think about this all the time because
the way forever for things to work,
the way they're working right now,
which is for there to be capitalism and
there to be super rich people and super
poor people in war and all the things
that you know or rather distasteful or
seem to be a, I seem to be a
destructive for that, to exist.
Each of those little nodes of
consciousness that represent
that bloodstream have
to think they're individuals and have
to think they're more important than all
the other ones. So you've got a bunch
of blood cells all thinking, yeah,
I got to get to work. What the fuck's
wrong with this asshole in front of me?
And not realizing they're all
part of this one super organism.
And if somehow everyone's consciousness
shifted from the idea of like,
I gotta get to work to whatever
the next thing would be,
which is I'm connected to this
super mind that is the planet,
which I think is going to,
that's what the singularity will be.
It will be some technologically, uh, uh,
applied empathy that allows everyone
to connect their consciousness to the
mother earth.
Yeah.
That moment capitalism kind of ceases
as we know it and capitalism, of course,
it's just a, it's a symptom of
something deeper. But that, that model,
the model that's running
everything is no longer possible.
Now,
model encourages a competition.
Not Model encourages people to push and
strive and push beyond their comfort in
order to, you know, to create more action
and create more money to create more,
more building, more
construction, more, more things,
more prisons, more la, buying more things,
more diseases so we can have more
realism this out. Yeah. All of it.
It all accelerates. They
invented diseases. It's a,
it's a fascinating thing
man. You know, the, uh,
the idea that everything moves in the
same direction is that the single celled
organisms, you know, that, you know, or
even how about we look at blood, you know,
when you're talking about it looking
like a blood moving through arteries,
you know, blood is a
single cell, you know,
single cells of blood move as in the
same as this huge animal that has a,
you know,
billions of cells and not just that but
is also a host for all sorts of bacteria
and stuff that live inside of our bodies.
But we have to,
in order to keep it going in the
same direction as those cells,
we have to have all these different little
tools that we use to sort of justify
existence. All these different little
tools like the love of having your baby.
Yeah.
The love of orgasms.
You know the love of going on stage or
of creating something you know or you
think about the one thing that's
the most satisfying, you know,
outside of childbirth and in having
your own children is creating, you know,
people who don't create things I think
as a whole are way less happy than people
who do create things.
And I know dudes that make pool cues.
I know dudes that make belts,
they make custom wallets and there's a
something that they get when they like,
you know,
I bought a wallet from this dude and you,
you buy a wallet from him and he sells
you the wallet and he made it for you and
shit. Like there's a smile that
he has. Like he created something,
he created a piece of artwork and
someone else is appreciating a, wow,
I love how you did this is wow, this is
awesome work. It's so clean and well done.
He's like, thank you. I
like his effort and his,
his creativity have gone
into an actual object.
And to us that's very,
very, very satisfying.
And then there's the comedy satisfaction
that you get for performing mean this
all we you and I understand. I mean, I
don't understand. I guess it's in music,
it's probably just the same thing.
You meet,
create a song and then people love
that song, creating something in.
Then what are you doing when you creating
something while you're doing the same
fucking thing. You're,
you're pushing the machine,
you're pushing it in your way and
your way is making people happy and,
and giving people some
positive energy by your DVD.
And there's an industry behind that
and they come see what the clubs,
and this is industry behind that.
Even behind putting gas in their cars
and you know, it's, it's, it's a really,
it's amazing how many different pieces
are in place. If you, if you take back,
if you like,
you know,
zoom in on the idea of what is creation
and creation is taking something from
the nothingness and bringing
it into the somethingness.
And so you sort of become the doorway
for something that come from the
nothingness into the something that's,
so when you're creating,
you're actually experiencing as flow
through from the infinite into the finite.
And that I think that is the feeling
that we love so much is that sense of
feeling that,
that thing when you're working on jokes
and all of a sudden it goes from being a
drudge to all of a sudden it's
like, Holy Shit, you know,
it's happening and all of a sudden you
get sucked into this weird vacuum and you,
you've written for like two hours
and it feels like a second. You know,
that that sense of being pulled into a
momentary current or something's coming
out of you that's clearly
not necessarily you.
That to me is like one of the ultimate.
It is, it's the ultimate feeling.
And I have the, you know, I think if
you go by this idea of this attractor,
the,
that Mckenna talks about,
or this thing that exists and hyperspace
that it's what it wants to come through,
I send to this universe that wants
to express itself through us. And,
um, I, I think that's the compulsion
that you're talking about.
I think that's an alternative
viewpoint obviously. Um,
there's the cynical way of looking
at it. Like, no, no, no, no.
That's a natural inclination that
people have. Monkeys are curious.
This is what we do.
We think about things.
And every joke that you have was
just priest a cumulation of your life
experiences and you're figuring
out a little bit, congratulations.
You're not tapping into the universal
consciousness will be ranked back.
Sarah Pailin is on the line and we're
going to have a nice little sit down with
a future president. The
United States maybe. Huh?
Well let's hope he doesn't fuck anybody
that he's not married to buy imaginary
rituals. Uh, th the thing about
it, but you know what I'm saying,
the cynical point of view
about the idea of creativity,
there's something to that point of
view too. You have to address it.
You can always go hippie.
And um, one of the things,
I bet I bounced back and
forth. I don't think it is
either, but it is a little. Um,
I bounced back and forth with the
idea of the imagination being a,
almost like when you,
when you have imagination that the
imagination is the real force behind the,
the evolution.
What imagination is is we think
of as like, oh, I can see things. I go and
work around problems. I have this idea.
But when you imagine an idea,
when you imagine a product,
do you imagine how to design an engine
for a car and you're the first, you know,
your Henry Ford or whoever the fuck made
the first engine. Yeah. When you're,
your imagination has this idea for this
thing and then you build it and design
it and boom, it's there.
That thought what there,
there was no thought of that before
it existed. It's not that it brought,
people were running around thinking of
the car and I know what's going to look
like. There was no thought of it.
You created this or it came to you.
There was a something from
nothing. Something from, from,
what is that from the ether.
Something from these.
Even if it's just these synapses
firing in your mind, where is the,
what does the signal, what is the root
of this signal to be? So you know,
mathematical about it and say,
wow,
it's just human ingenuity
and that's what it is.
It's good old sticktuitiveness and you
roll up your sleeves and you figure out
this world. I want that Henry Ford
created a great thing and you know,
whilst in there and chop my shadows or
news or great felly and federal budgets,
neurons sweating. Yeah. You know,
I don't necessarily know it's,
it is possible that the imagination is
something that is information that is out
there like the, the idea of the akashic
records, the idea of uh, you know, yeah,
there's shit out there and then we'll,
we are his little antennas and that our,
when we tune into something,
if we pick up this,
this signal for the engine and
someone picks that up, excellent.
Once that piece is in place, oh and
then it flowers and blossoms, like,
like a Fibonacci sequence on a
fucking a sunflower, you know,
it all bursts out, you know,
exponentially in certain directions.
And then that starts creating more
inventions with all, which also burst out.
But all of them emanate in
the imagination. Initially.
All of them have to be thought up auto.
All of them have to be created
by the human minds, right?
Or what the human mind can tune into.
There's no
play into this universe as a human,
but through a pussy and there's no way.
Now,
there is no way for an idea to come into
this universe except through a thought.
There's no way for an invention
except to come through our mind.
Our minds are the,
our minds are sort of the creative
orifice is through which all innovation,
every invention, every idea comes,
it's through the human mind. Now,
if you want to think that some day you
just wake up and you get in the shower
and you get lucky enough for your neurons
to fire a certain way where you figure
out how to reduce the cost of making
solar power panels and solve the, uh,
you know,
the energy problem on the planet.
If you want to think that that's
an accident, fine. If it helps you,
it seems like it helps a lot of people
to think that the universe springs from
some kind of lightening pole adding
plasma or the earth eyes or humor or
biological life on the earth. And some
people like to think that their neurons
get lucky and fire cause they squeeze
their brow together in the right way and
popped out an idea. But I think you'll
find that most of the great creators,
they don't think that
you know when you write,
but is that because the best way to
create this and not think about yourself?
The best way to create is like when
you start thinking about yourself,
the ego starts tripping over his own dick
and you start thinking about like how
cool you are.
Yeah.
That's like when you see a guy on stage
and the guy like obviously thinks she's
cool. The worst it's the worst is
the feeling is this feeling of gross.
Nist is a disconnect and that disconnect
also disconnects him from creativity.
Whereas if you see a guy on stage
and he's just in the moment, man,
he doesn't give a fuck.
He just tuned into it.
It's so compelling and so interesting,
you know,
so maybe it's a trick,
you know what I'm saying?
Like maybe this idea that you know that
we are tuning into the infinite and that
is maybe not,
maybe it just requires a certain state
of mind to be creative and that state of
mind is to avoid the ego.
It's also like, like the car,
they don't just invent the car,
you invent the wheel first and it's
because somebody sat there like, Hey,
I need to take stone or take
heavy thing over here. You know,
I understand the intent of that movie.
I think it's awesome.
Necessity inventions come with necessity.
It certainly is. But guess what?
Antelopes on event and shit. They keep
getting jacked by Jaguars left and right.
They're stupid fucks.
They never figure it out every year.
They never invented Anil mobe car where
they can just give the finger to the
Jaguar, beep the horn run over the
Jaguar babies they see in the road,
they can't do it.
We can.
And the one of the reasons why we can is
because we're conscious because we can
think and, but what is thinking?
The real question is what are,
what are all these things firing together,
solving problems.
What is all that really? Because some
people can't solve shit. There's,
it's very clear that there's a,
there's different types of people.
There's people that are super solvers
and there's people that can barely solve
taking a shit and wiping
their ass correctly.
There's people that can barely
show up for work every day.
Everything they do is a fucking mass
and they make more people that are just
like that. Well, if you think that
there's an order to the whole thing,
what are those fucks here for?
You know,
are they here just until robots can
become invented to do menial tasks?
Is that what it is? Well, yeah.
Here's the thing. What you did,
this is what you do especially eat them.
You think of an IC,
you know when things get bad, for sure
they think of like the greatest idea ever.
Your brain's though. Then he'd get mad
cow disease. Try On's will fuck you up.
You can, if you cannibalize your
candidate, every, the brain, the brain,
just the lags, nature, nature's balls and
Asshole, they're rates are goes bitch,
you got a problem,
people brains you fucking crazy pictures.
They're delicious. If you
look at, if you, so the idea,
just to get back to this idea of
like where do thoughts come from?
Well if you,
if you take things out of the temporal
perspective and look at things as some
unified whole,
and by temporal you mean
by present and future.
Okay.
So let's look at the whole thing
is like from the perspective,
if we could jump out of time and we
could look at whatever this event was,
let's call it the big bang for now and
the series of reactions that happened
directly after the Big Bang and those
first few seconds that the people at the
particle accelerators want to understand.
And then you follow that all the
way to the condensation of gas.
I guess that made matter,
an event and the galaxies and the guy.
And then you follow all the way
that to the first, uh, uh, mix,
chemical soup that,
whatever that was.
And then the DNA starts
forming out of that.
And then that DNA somehow
gets encapsulated in a
membrane and we have cells in
the cells,
gained symbiotic relationships with
other cells and become multicellular
organisms, which have
symbiotic relationships. And
eventually you end up with us.
We still are at basically a DNA trail
going all the way back to before DNA to
matter, all the way back
to this explosion of light.
And so a thought is an idea,
a merging from infinity from the ultimate
explosion trillions of years ago and
to the present moment. Now, if
that ain't come in from nowhere,
I don't know what is, you can say,
well no, it's my neurons that did it.
Well your neurons did it right now,
but you're a chain of super reactions
that led to this moment in time when you
invented the thing you invented, right?
You know, you're not just your neurons,
you are connected to the an
entire ecosystem and you're
connected to a infinite
past. You know? And it's
just, I guess when you start
looking at things that just,
you know,
there's your 60 year lifespan,
I suppose things can start looking
pretty grim and Penn and teller ish.
But if you really just step out of time
and really look at what's going down,
it's like it's fucking crazy,
man.
We got blasted out of some infinite passed
and we're like yapping about it right
now.
Well,
it seems to me that we are passengers
on a spaceship that is about three hours
from slamming into another planet and
we just woke up from hyperspace. Yeah.
And we're looking at the maps and we
are going, how the fuck did we get here?
What are we doing here?
Does anybody is a radar online yet?
We are starting to decipher radar,
sir.
But we do have a window and we're
moving very close to something.
We're not exactly sure what it is.
Yeah. And then you know. Exactly.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like we're waking up in the middle
of history right now and all of us are
some, at some point in time
we're realizing that, oh my God,
there were no one has a firm grip on
exactly what the fuck is going on.
We really are like a space ship
about the slam into something.
You really are moving. We have massive
momentum. We're in a tractor beam.
We all keep going. Yeah, we're
moving towards that thing.
But we're all moving in
this certain very tangible,
very physical direction.
And no one knows exactly why,
but everyone keeps it going. And we
kind of have to keep it going. I mean,
that's one of the beautiful things about
materialism and all these different
things is that if these things are in
place, man, do, you're forced, you know,
I'm writing, you know, writing a book and
now one of the chapters, it's all about,
it's called, um, uh, if you get cancer
from your cell phone, your fucking pussy.
So maintaining your manhood and ever
changing world is the idea of it.
That as things become
more and more complicated,
it's very difficult to be true to your,
your nature as a human being, as a man,
and that one of the biggest ways that
you become a bitch is you get a job and
get jobs.
We'll turn you into a bitch more than
anything that a man and counters in his
whole life, having a boss, having
something that you don't want to do,
that becomes most of your life.
Most of your life is eight hours a
day that you're waking the, the, the,
the two plus commuting hours you throw
in there, the most of that is it.
Shit you don't want to do.
Your life becomes mostly what you don't
want to do and then once you start
getting things and that you have to
pay for her car payment or an apartment
rental or God forbid,
you start fucking shit now the kids and
they don't have to pay for them. Yeah.
Then you become a real bitch because
then you can't say what you want because
you're worried about getting fired. You
know? I've had people say that to me.
Like you say things like that.
Do you ever worry that the UFC is
going to say something or do you, well,
I'm in the luxurious position where
I don't have to worry about that,
but God damn, fuck yeah, of
course I would, you know,
if I was barely getting by and I didn't
have money saved up and I didn't have
other career paths,
you know,
being a comedian is the most beautiful
fucking thing to ever have as your main
occupation because we can
always go to that, you know,
and we can always speak our mind and
if people know they can count on you.
Like one of the reasons why this podcast
is so successful is because there is no
bullshit going on in this podcast.
There's a lot of speculation.
There's a lot of what ifs.
There's a lot of stoner talk,
but every fucking thing that I say,
I say because I believe it I owl or I'm,
I'm being honest about my thoughts,
right?
Just not a lot of people that are
thinking like that in this world.
There's not a lot of people who have
the luxury with their job to be honest
about their points of view
all throughout the day.
But what do you do? And this is something
that I always wonder and I share it.
You're at this idea that you have I,
and you're right,
having a job is a form of slavery.
When you get locked into the system,
you get locked into the machine.
But what would the world be like
if you applied this philosophy?
If everyone on the planet heard you
saying that and suddenly left their jobs?
Yeah, it would be
impossible. Why do we have,
we have far too complex society where
there's a bunch of shit that needs to get
done that nobody wants to do. What
is that? Oh, I really want to know,
like this is an idea I always want to
explore is like what it, what Ha. Okay,
let's just say it just for a thought
experiment. Everyone on the planet,
this thing happens in the spaceship.
They all wake up and we're all
looking at what we're doing.
90% of what we do is robotic,
ritualistic bullshit that that is not
allowing us to fully experience life.
We'll do it be some good
things that would happen.
Like government jobs that are
completely useless would go away.
Like the real stupid jobs that
are only in place because the government
wants to provide jobs and make
government bigger because it's one of
the ways they can show they're doing well
and helping the economy. You
know, that's a, that's a terrible,
horrible trap and that would be, those
people would be forced to contribute.
That would be something you,
you're going to now forced to actually
have something that you, you know,
you're going to give to
society and they're going to
give you food in return for
this thing. You know, they're
going to give you clothing,
they're going to get you.
It's going to be some sort of a
system in place. You know the,
the real problem though is what about
all the shit that nobody wants to do?
Right? What about create, what have I'm
making computers. What about landscape?
Yeah.
What are we going to do without,
but we're going to only have third world
countries that are handling our shit.
And this, this entire country becomes
a bunch of lay abouts with no jobs.
See,
that's where it gets fun.
There's a lot of people that have jobs
that have bosses that love their fucking
job. You love being a landscaper or they
love the NRA. They love being a true,
totally true. But those numbers are
pretty small. Yeah, absolutely. Anything.
It's 10% I don't think you're 10% of
the people I know love their job. Well,
I'll tell you, he loves their
job. Mcdonald's workers.
Have you ever gone into a Mcdonald's?
It's like a temple of happiness.
Those people are just miserable.
Grease stain,
the, the, the, the, so, but
I, this is, uh, you know,
speaking of hippies on the way.
That's a good point that you brought
up because they're replacing Dunkin Dot
Dunkin donuts. They're replacing
Mcdonald's employees, the
with kiosks. They have that already
at del Taco by my house or not.
Don't talk at El Pollo Loco and you just
go up and it's just like everything's
touch screen and you just
slide your card and Bam.
Now man, cause how many
McDonald's customers can read.
But you know what the best is,
is being able to actually for once
order everything exactly how you want to
without having to waste the
person's time. You know, like,
like you order your burger, you're
like, yeah, I don't want Manet's. Oh,
like mustard ketchup. Yeah. Let's
add this. Let's add like your,
for once you're actually being able to
order shit exactly how you want without
making people feel bad
anymore. Man, I can't do it.
If you see food inc Jesus fucking Christ,
watch that and then go have a
fucking make rib or whatever
card. Yeah, it changed my, uh, my
whole philosophy and all that stuff.
I still eat fish though.
Fuck fish.
Flatfish that's all I eat it like
burger king or Mcdonald's rather.
Are you filet of fish? Lifelong
enemy. If the crab really I have no,
I feel I did not feel bad about
eating crabs. Crabs suck. But like,
I don't feel bad about eating seafood.
I can't feel sorry for fish.
It's really difficult.
You don't take care of their young,
so I need to know about fish. They
eat other fish. They eat other fish.
Dethroned by the way,
you can catch bash all you can
catch bass on little tiny bass.
[inaudible] it look like bass. We can
catch them. They eat little baby bass.
The moment cons. You eat your own species.
Yeah. I don't feel bad eating here. Yeah,
they'd shit their shit. The
rugs out. The guy comes over.
It doesn't mean fuck the girl.
Just Jesus all over the eggs.
It's like what kind of a stupid,
they're so disconnected you them perverts.
If the seat,
well they can't stop for even a second.
Even the fuck there's no time and your
soul is going to come along and eat your
ass.
Some eggs on the world of the,
of the ocean and of lakes is so fantastic
and bizarre and and really alien to
us. Hedberg I have a joke about how awful
the ocean would be. A fish gets scream.
It wouldn't be mad. You think about it,
everybody's a murderer. Even whales,
a murderers,
wells go around eating krill.
You know there's very few vegetarian fish
and it doesn't matter because even the,
whatever vegetarian foods there are,
they get killed.
I mean the ones that do exist
that eat algae and shit like that,
you just there to clean up bitch and then
every now and then someone's going to
come around and eat your ass,
chomp out an experimental chomp.
How often does a shark, a human
swimming? They don't like getting humans,
but they take an experimental bike,
they're hungry,
they're hungry and you're easy and the
rest of the world is moving very fast and
leave this fucking stupid
thing with rubber flippers.
It's barely moving just like
this fucking thing real quick.
It's like eating like something out of
your refrigerator that you're just like,
man,
maybe it's still good.
I don't surf.
I have friends that do it and they say
it's the most amazing thing of all time,
but fucking man,
every year someone gets jacked.
I was using the analogy that if every
year someone got attacked by the wolf man,
would you still go in the woods during a
full moon? Now, why the fuck would you?
Well guess what? Sharks are way
scarier than the god Damn Wolf Man.
Cause they're real and they don't
take days off. It's not like,
oh it's on a full moon.
We don't have to worry.
We can go swimming in the ocean now know
every fucking day sharks are out there
and they're way scarier than Werewolf.
But isn't it like the odds of you getting
in a shark attack like your, your,
your odds will be better if you know,
getting hit by like a meteor or something.
Like do you know what, you
know, they're not that small.
It depends on where you're at.
If you go to South Africa that your odds
are very high that you're going to get
bit by sharks.
There's an area in South Africa where
they can drag a surfboard behind a boat
and there's videos of it cause it's
that fucked up cause they have a huge
population in South Africa
of great white sharks.
And People Go fucking surfing out there,
man.
And you'll drag a boat or drag a surfboard
behind a great white or brown behind
a boat and a great way would just
come along and nail it. They had one,
they dragged it, didn't just
dragged it for like five minutes.
Three sharks nailed it in five minutes.
It's heroin.
And one of the,
one of the,
aside from being permanently crippled
and terrified at the seed for the rest of
your life,
one of the awful things about being a
shark attack victim is always hearing that
fucking statistic.
My odds of getting bitten by a shark
and you're looking at your stub like,
yeah, fuck that statistic. I got
uh, my, my arm ripped off dude.
Recently a write up in Santa
Barbara that got bitten half,
he a hundred yards from shore swimming
with his buddies in a 16 foot great white
came along and bid him in
half. And they were like, well,
it's real rare for shark like that to
exist in this part of the world. Yeah.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Just because it's
rare. It's still the ocean.
It's all connected. Yeah.
The ocean is one big playing
field. Okay. There's no nets.
There's the occasionally
nets for fish of course,
but there's nothing that separates this
part of the fucking field from the other
part of the field. There's just habitat
and they choose if they want to,
they can keep swimming.
They can take a chance.
They're in a certain area for a reason.
It's because the food sources there,
but guess what?
There's a reason why with some killer
whales are up near Alaska us cause they
found a fucking food source.
They wandered that area,
started killing things there and said
I was a good spot. Now Shit moves man.
Ocean is like a giant buffet
tray and when you go into a,
you become part of the buffet.
Whether you like it or not,
you're your anything in the ocean could
eat you and there's so many things that
would love to that. That last moment,
dude, that's what I think about.
You're out there swimming,
body surf and having fun.
You see your girl on the
shore, hey, you're swimming.
Then all of a sudden it
feels like somebody punched
you really hard in the leg
and then you look down and there's
just blood guys are hanging out at your
fucking ripped arteries and there's just,
there's just some white shape underneath
you carrying your leg off to Atlanta
has and that and you know what I mean?
That's your last moment as you sink under
the waves and suck in water because he
lost so much blood. Maybe you wake up
in the hospital two days later. Right.
But you know what,
how is that any better than the cows last
day when that fucking pissed and goes
to his brain a couple of days before
you eat them in a cheeseburger.
Not a good last day. Last Day.
Everybody's last day. Sox Win.
Not necessarily really. You think
your last day is going to be the shit?
I think that there, well, I
mean yes because it depends
on how you do it, I guess.
Depends on how you do it, but some key
survival stash of mushrooms around,
you know,
like a real,
like a 10 gram stash that you
can just bust into it every time.
Then you'll like this, this mother fucker.
It looks like it's, yeah, this is it.
You know, I'm, I'm drowning in my own
lung fluid here. You know, my, my,
my feet or black with rot. Okay,
it's over. I can't breathe.
We just chew down these
mushrooms real quick.
Just like fucking out of this HUD
families like, father, please don't do it.
Don't take those things.
We want you here when you're dying.
Leave us.
You're just trying to have a nice little
mushroom trip before you blast off.
You know,
out of this Huxley on his deathbed wrote
because he couldn't talk on a sheet of
paper,
the medical prescription for 500
micrograms of LSD intravenously,
which his wife injected
and do him on his deathbed.
He's the guy who wrote brave new world.
Oh my God, I'm not tripping. Wow.
Have you heard of Bitcoin? What
have you heard of Bitcoin? Spell it.
B. I. T. C. O I n no,
it's this new peer to peer currency
that's going on the Internet right now.
It's kind of based off of Torrance. You
know, I know what you're talking about.
You're talking about that psychedelic
store where you can buy anything you want.
I don't, I was wondering if
you guys knew about that.
There's a store that if
you set up your computer
correctly,
like you have to put like some kind of
make it random like IP addresses so it's
not trackable.
Then you can access to this access as
one website called the silk roads. Yeah,
and you can pretty much
buy any drug you want to.
And these guys have been buying acid.
They're using bitcoins though,
so it's even more untraceable. Is it
really untraceable I doubt it. Yeah.
I think I, I think
anyone could fuck, yeah,
it seems like the dumbest age of wired
for those folks who don't know what we're,
well if you just Google,
this is the phrase to Google,
the underground website where
you can buy any drug imaginable.
If you Google that,
it'll come up a bunch of
different articles from bunch
of different publications.
I read the one in wired magazine,
which just one of my favorite
online things to read.
I use Gawker Gawker's awesome too.
Uh,
but basically what they're saying is that,
you know,
it describes a guy who did it. It's
this guy here, I'll describe it.
Three weeks ago, US Postal
Service delivered an ordinary
envelope to Mark's door.
Inside was a tiny plastic bag
containing 10 tabs of LSD.
If you had opened it,
unless you were looking for it,
you wouldn't have even noticed mark,
a software developer had
ordered 100 micrograms of
acid through a listing in the
online marketplace.
Silk Road.
He found a seller with lots of good
feedback who seemed to know what they were
talking about. Added the acid to his
digital shopping car and hit checkout.
He entered his address and
paid the seller 50 bitcoins,
untraceable digital
currency worth about $150.
Four days later, the drugs sent
from Canada arrived at his house.
Um, what was the website
that you order? The LSD.
That seems to me like this is one of
those things that was a great idea for a
little,
but until everybody started talking
about until Gawker put it on their front
page. Yeah. Or wired. It's
actually emanated from Gawker.
I did like the idea of bitcoin. So
trying to start a currency, you know,
outside of the normal currency,
you got it.
You got to have balls to order LSD.
That I would start off with Tylenol pm
and then work my way up cause you gotta
give me your address. I'm going to no
matter what. That seems just crazy.
I couldn't enjoy that.
I do the acid you'd get
so God damn paranoid that
someone was going to boot down
your door and fucking stick a gun in your
mouth while you're sleeping and scream
at you. Where's the fucking
drug? Shoot your dog. You know,
I mean, did you hear about the DEA raid
and fucking, I think it was an Arizona.
We're a guy who was a former marine,
was a gun down in a,
in an ill conceived drug raid.
They shot him 71 times.
He had a little Baggie of weakness house.
Yeah, I heard of that. Yeah, that's,
that's the kind of shit that are
really killed. Hi. Yeah, no shit.
That shit kills my eye anyway.
That's like it.
That's how I know I'm
about to have a bad trip.
Is that the fantasy swat team starts.
It's surrounding the house.
Well that's the problem also in
environments where drugs are illegal,
psychedelic drugs,
marijuana where those things that
you'd want and are nice and they're
illegal end. When you buy them,
you have to be in contact with bad people.
You have to be in contact
with drug dealers.
with people who are willing,
willing to risk going to
jail to sell you this shit.
And a lot of times these fucking guys
get popped and a lot of times maybe they
don't like you. So when they get popped
and they have to talk to the cops,
the cops is, where are you
getting this shit from? Hey,
I'm buying this from this former marine
man. This guy's fucking crazy. You know,
he's got a gun and he's selling coke at
his house. And so what did the cops do?
Well they said,
well we've got to fucking far marine and
coke and the guy's crazy and he's got
guns. We need to get the swat team
together, put on the vest and the helmets.
And so then they fucking gun this guy
down when really maybe all it was is he
knew a shithead cause that's
where he bought his pot.
You know who the fuck knows?
I mean I'm reading into the whole thing.
He might've been crazy,
but when you,
my point is when you're dealing
with the world of illegal drugs,
you're dealing with
criminals. Right. And that's,
that's one of the biggest
travesties of, you know, the,
the having these personal freedoms taken
away from us is that it's forcing you
to interact with people.
We're at a father fucking mind. But
that's the annoying thing. Yeah.
Cause you know, you hear, listen,
marijuana is a gateway drug.
You start smoking marijuana,
you're going to have a heroin needle
hanging out your arm by Christmas.
But it's like really marijuana
is not a gateway drug.
Drug dealers are gateway drugs.
And when a kid can't go to a store that
solely sells marijuana and goes to a
dope dealer in some trailer, North
Carolina, like where I used to go,
the guy's like, hey boy, you want to,
but you want to try and get an eight
ball on top of that. It's great coke.
And then the next thing you know
you're like, oh sure, why not?
I'll try some coke or I'll try some meth.
That's one way you're looking at it.
But I could see that someone who's curious
and tries marijuana would eventually
be curious and try heroin or be
curious and try math. Or you know,
if they have friends that
are dumb, especially if
you're young, it's very deep.
If you do math, I know this person that
fucking moron, you are a fucking moron.
But what of your dumb and what a few
young and what if you have a friend who
just did math and he's like, it was crazy.
It was wild. I thought you get hooked.
No, no, no, no. I'm fine. I'm
fine. And you're dominant.
You listened to your dumb friend and
then boom, you're doing math. You know,
I can see that,
but it still doesn't take away from the
fact that one of the main problems is
that we have this distrust of
the, uh, the, the entire system.
We have a distrust of the
police and the law enforcement,
distrust of the lawmakers.
And one of the big reasons for
this distrust is marijuana laws.
We know they're ridiculous.
They know they're ridiculous.
It's 2000 fucking 11.
And you go online and you
look up the statistics and
you look up all the studies.
You go, well, hey, this shit isn't deadly
at all. Not always. It's not deadly.
It seems to shrink tumors.
And look,
it seems to help people with add
and it seems to help children.
When you go online,
you find the information.
It's so completely diametrically opposite
of what they're fucking telling you
and beaten your, your, your head.
And with that you start to disregard
what they say about other shit too.
And then you try math because you say,
well fuck,
they were lying to me about weed. Maybe
methane that bad. You know, maybe coke's
not a big deal.
And then all these fucking terrible,
really dangerous drugs that are,
I don't know if you've had a friend that
has had an addiction problem and been
there weather while they're
in the throes of addiction.
It's like having a friend that's bit
by a vampire. Yeah, it really is.
It's like you can't do anything
for them. You can't, you're,
you're holding them down.
Their fangs are popping out and
it's like you see them shaking.
Shuddering sweating. What did you,
what was your friend? What happened?
What did you have a,
my friend was addicted to Vicodin and
I went over to his house because he's
like, can you come get rid
of my Vicodin? And I'm like,
I'll be right over because
it is, I love biking. It
has a good friend.
You went through a period of time where
you got a bunch of pills and you got
real weird for a while. Man, I
dunno what the fuck you were taken,
but you took too much of it and you kept
taking it. You were telling me, dude,
if I have it in my house, I just take
them. Yeah. It's like world of Warcraft,
I to flush them down the toilet.
What was it? What were they? Well,
so what had happened is a
friend of mine who really isn't,
I clearly probably not the night sky,
just gave me a fucking handful,
a shitload of pills,
like its own weird mixture of pills.
So like I,
I think I was a little depressed at
the time and like listening to a lot of
Elliot Smith. Oh No, it's okay. Go stab
themselves today. Yeah. So like I went,
I was living in echo park and have these
pills and I go into my depressed little
apartment, like eat
pills. It was really it
dark time, man. And, and,
and uh, and I got sick. I
wouldn't, I guess you could say,
I don't think I got physically addicted.
I don't think I got a habit,
but I got a little
psychologically addicted and I
got scared because I could see
the, you know, the fucking,
I could feel the pole,
so I flushed them down the toilet.
Wow. That's a smart move. That's
it. Hard move to make though, right?
You were at the door of addiction,
right?
Yeah. And I could feel, I could,
I could see where it could go.
Um,
and that's why fucking pills suck.
And that's why you should avoid them at
all costs because they fucking suck. I,
you know,
I just threw my back out and my
dad gave me some pain medication,
which I took and this is the first time
I've taken like a pharmaceutical pain
killer and a long time and I hated it.
It just made me feel like shit,
I was puking yesterday.
I don't know if that it was from that or
the fact that we had pregnant old shell
fish or I'm pregnant, but like
those things suck, man. Uh,
all pills, uh, suck.
They're terrible for you,
but they're awful for you.
Outside of like, you know,
Xanax and Oxycontin,
which I still use every day.
I do, I did kind of see your, your drug,
your drug dealer giving you
kind of like the gateway thing.
I know a friend that allegedly recently
went to go get mushrooms and this person
has only done we'd and
mushrooms and their whole life.
And the first thing the guy says,
hey, I got some DMT right now also.
And it was like,
can you imagine just giving somebody TMT
going from like, oh, what's the DMT?
I'll try that. That shit's all my fault.
I Know Jeff,
you started a DMT explosion.
Crazy. But I did. How often do
you get emails from fake cops?
Probably every day. I don't,
I can't respond to emails
anymore. It's impossible.
I get too many of them.
So don't even try.
I do what I can to respond to Twitter
messages and nice short form things and
talk to people outside of clubs, you
know, after shows and stuff like that.
But there's just too many people wanting
my time and too many crazy fucking
people. But there's definitely fake
cops. There's definitely other cops.
Fake people returning to your cops,
I'm sure. But look, it's real simple.
I always say like, I don't travel with
it. I don't, I don't, uh, you know,
I'm not looking to get high and other
towns, I'm not looking at, you know,
get fucked up on mushrooms in Seattle.
I'm not, I'm not doing anything stupid.
And I have a respect for law enforcement.
I know that they know these laws are
retarded. I have no, a lot of cops, man,
believe me.
What they hate is criminals.
They hate scumbags and murderers and
people knocking over fucking people stores
and houses and stealing
and making societies suck.
And a lot of that is drug dealers
too because as we said, you know,
people were willing to take those
fucking chances to sell drugs.
A lot of times they're doing that because
they were doing something else before.
They had some fucking pyramid scheme
before that and before that they were,
you know, selling stolen car radios
or there's a lot of people involved.
When you get involved
in that illegal world,
the world of Shit that can
get you locked up in jail.
There's a lot of people that only
operate inside that realm. You know,
they go from one little illegal scam to
the next cops hate them and they should
for a fucking reason. I
personally like cops, you know,
people think that because I like pot,
I don't like cops.
Cops to me are a huge fucking important
part of a healthy and safe society.
And when you hear about bad cops,
I personally believe that it's a,
a small fraction of the actual cops.
Most cops are,
they behaved admirably in front
of a bunch of fucking cunts.
Cause that's what most people are.
Most people are dumb cunts and they're
out there doing dumb stupid shit.
And these cops running these dumb cons
doing dumb stupid shit all day fucking
long. Every day of the week. I admire
their fucking patients for the most part.
By the way,
I'd love to see the cop painters out
there cause I think fallen apart in you're
ready because the way you handle it. No,
I just tend just touch them. I like that.
And it did it. It's fine. You sit
right on top of your belly too.
Maybe you should like back
that bitch up a little bit.
So you know there's some space between
me and the microphone. I'd love to see,
I'd love to see what a copywriter does
when they're fucking house gets broken
into. Yeah. Cops. Some cops are bad man.
I know a guy who was selling
weed who got robbed by cops.
Don't think I've talked
about it on the podcast.
I've never had a problem with cops.
I think if you have a problem
with cops for the most part,
watch the show cops and you'll realize
what these cops are dealing with. They,
they seem pretty nice and then they're
dealing with it, but like you said,
a bunch of fucking retards or
watch Steven Seagal law. Man,
what the fuck is he doing?
He's a cop. He just busted
a cock fighting ring and Arizona.
They bridged,
drove into a house with the fucking
tank and they busted people fighting
roosters. Steven, look, dog gets
out. This is real life, man.
He's so strange to me. God is no one
more bizarre to me and Steven Seagal.
It's hilarious. Why did he drive into
a chicken house to the tank? Well,
I did our TV. Why did real cops let him
come to a bust? The whole thing. I mean,
I guess he's some sort of a weird
real cop in Louisiana I guess.
I don't even think he is. I think he
just shadows them or something like that.
I think he's like an
honorary sort of a thing.
Like Shaq was Shaquille O'Neal
was like an honorary sheriff.
Well he loves chickens.
Shaquille O'Neal, Steven to,
he just loves chickens. These are my
precious, these are God's children.
I don't give a fuck about birds either.
Birds to me are just like fish.
I have a pen. Go fuck themselves. Guilty
eating chickens cause those little,
those little fucking orange checks.
There's Tony chicks eat chickens.
Chickens are cunts.
Once they become full grown,
their cuts chop their fucking
heads off and cook them up.
I don't have no problem with eating
chickens. They're cold blooded assholes.
They don't give a fuck
about you slap a chicken.
I do jokes about birds like people.
So like saying that the apocalypse and
the birds are falling from the sky as the
apocalypse and I'm like, you don't know
if people were falling from the sky,
it would be the apocalypse.
Like birds. I said my pet bird,
the moment he died, that thing's
going to eat your fucking eyeballs
about you,
man.
Let it shitheads something happened and
saw that fucking offered Hitchcock movie
the birds. I just watched that today's
I got, that's happened to birds. Hey,
have you seen somebody back then
didn't have a fucking shotgun?
That that is the dumbest fucking movie.
If there was common sense,
that movie would not exist if it was
so retarded that there were so many,
like just watching it.
Like,
why don't you just fucking get
in that room and don't move?
Why are you having bird attacks
and you're scared of birds,
but you're still going outside at
all. You know what I mean? They,
every time somebody went
outside, somebody died. Oh,
how come nobody's got a goddamn
tennis racket up in this bitch?
I'll tell you what, these are only crows
are right. If it was crows outside,
oh fuck. Off Off Hosan Crows.
I'll go out there with a,
a goalie mask on and uh,
some sparring gear like to cover up all
my vital areas and a cop and to tennis
rackets,
and I'll take on a swarm of birds.
I'll just swap those pitches out of the
sky. It would be an awesome workout.
Cro advocate here,
if a big enough flock of
crows descended on you, yes.
They could carry you away. That's true.
Yes it was. Because what happened?
I would be a whirling dervish like a
fucking tornado of tennis racquets or
you're going to get swooped into. That
may be you, but I got some cardio bitch.
I work out. The real product
would be if it was eagles,
if you had a swarm of eagles,
you're dead dead.
Never seen the videos of
eagles killing wolves.
Yup. Yeah. What the fuck did you know?
They train them to kill wolves because
they get the wolf furs and they sell like
wolf pelts are worth a lot of money
because you know a lot of the guys where
they do it,
you know they're,
they're farmers and shit and they have
sheep and the wolves come and eat the
sheep. So they, they, they
train eagles to kill the wolves.
And I would've never
believed it was so easy.
These eagles are like undefeated
versus walls feel sorry for the world.
That's incredible. Feel bad for the,
they swooped down and they just Jack.
These motherfuckers grab them by their
necks and you realize like an eagle has
like they have like five
fucking knives in each hand.
You know how many closets they have?
I don't have feet. I don't know. Four.
Let's go. Let's go with,
you can see on the Internet,
but they in basically they
have some fucking wolverine
type weapon and they just
grab the neck of this wolf
and just fuck him up, man.
Yeah,
but it's not just that.
It seems like they get them by the neck
and then they plunge their beacon to him.
They just, oh, their beak is a
murderous weapon. A Cessna stone.
When I watched birds that I thought the
blonde chick was so hot in that movie
that I was like online trying to
find out if she was alive. Five.
You ever thought like leg fucking somebody
that was so desirable back in the day
and it still fucking hurt just
because of who's just used to be,
a lot of guys are still doing that.
I would fuck that girl.
You ever watch a celebrity rehab this
this season? I think so. You know,
Janice Dickinson,
she's that model who's a,
seems like a troubled lady.
I'm sure she's a nice person,
but she's got a lot of issues and she's
always like fucked up and Rehab and
she's got a lot of plastic surgery and
she's got this young boyfriend and his
boyfriend is like really not a very good
looking guy and he shouldn't be with
Janice tickets.
You know,
if Janice Dickinson was 20 there's no
way she'd be with this fucking dude.
But you know, he's 30 and
she's 50 or whatever the fuck
she is. And he's, you know,
he's with Janice Dickinson,
that plastic surgery phase that all droop.
She's got like early eighties
plastic surgery or they hadn't,
it hadn't evolved to where it's at.
So it's kind of fallen off the blonde
checks daughter with somebody like Melanie
Griffin or something like that too.
I was, I was like, wow, really? Yeah,
I hate those puffed lips now. And people
so say gel in their lips. Friend of mine,
his wife did that and I had a conversation
with her and I had to avoid looking
at it while we're talking.
I'm like,
oh gross that you expect an alien
to pop out of it. It was so weird.
She had just done it,
you know.
Have you ever had a time to have
three and then the bottom one,
that's what it seems like the wolves have.
There's a video online called
Golden Eagle domination.
It's just eagles fucking up everything.
Fucking of wolves and rabbits and just
swooping down and snatching things.
I got to see a few of those fly when I
lived in Colorado, I saw a golden eagles.
They actually live there. You can catch
them in the woods. Um, yeah, they're,
they're pretty scary man. That whenever I
see them fly over, I always think of it,
decided to attack me,
take my eyes at this video should showed
one just ate a fucking Turkey and then
one just caught a deer. There's a dare,
some murderous mother fuckers. Man,
there's a Fox jacked. This is just
an all, there's the wolf hope.
Fuck man. Watch this shit.
Watch a shit. Yeah, dude,
you're going to freak freak out,
man. They're so big. We don't realize how
big they are. First of all, look at this.
God takes the wolf down and grabs him
by the neck and just kills his ass.
You don't realize how big these
fucking things are. Look at this man.
Look at that. He flipped him over
and the poor. Whoa. Look at that.
Boom Dude. They kill wolves. Wow.
The natural world is so scary,
man.
There's so much crazy shit going
on in the natural world. Yeah.
It's like a big barroom brawl that she's
been going on for after constant fight,
but I mean the,
the,
the really nutty thing that our little
pea brains is the idea that almost
everything in the world eats and
kills everything else with its face,
the most intimate way possible to
grabs things in with it's fucking face.
Just reps things apart and that's no,
that's how life,
that's how life passes on. That's
the cycle of life. The cycle of life,
his teeth and claws and just
murder and tearing with your face.
Yeah. Wrestle it down. Get your face
inside. It's rib cage and eat its heart.
Does Golden Eagle is a bad motherfucker
now he's pulling goats off of cliffs
ever.
See when they do that,
they pull them off cliffs and just
drop them on the rock. Which is that,
this is something I've
wondered about that.
What did they do it that's like
a tool that they use or is that,
did that guy just catch an
accident happening? Well,
they do it a lot. It's, it's,
it's common but it's also a product of
the environment where they're fighting
them. If they were on, it looks
to me like to do an an on purpose,
but it also could be that
the trying to pick them up,
but they're doing it over
and over and over again.
But it also where they're fighting or
they're trying to kill these things and
fly off with them.
I mean it's in a a crazy spot where if
you go six inches to the right or six
inches to the left,
you're going to fall 3000 fucking feet
is this one's flying off with one,
but then he gets to the
bottom and he lets it go.
So I think they're trying
to fly off with them.
But Eagles are such evil fuck eds that
they'd try to bite off shit that they
can't even carry.
They try to like claw into this big,
big goat and fly away with it and
they can't. So like all right,
well I'll just see at the bottom and
just drop it. You look at this, this one,
a tax a bear. Well it's good for,
the energy's good there. You know,
you're expending fewer
calories and that's like,
isn't that what it's all
about when you're an animal,
you're conserving energy
and trying to get,
trying to get more energy before
you run out. We are so lucky.
There's no Mortera doctorals uh,
could you imagine,
cause that's what a
fucking bird is by the way,
which people don't understand
is that a bird is a dinosaur.
That is the direct descendants of
dinosaurs. They are the closest
thing that we have to understanding
what real dinosaurs look like for that
things. Do they run times?
Did you know about that? Yeah.
Chickens will grow Fang sometimes.
Wow. Fucking hate chickens.
They think a lot of dinosaurs actually
had feathers to dinosaurs that existed
even in, uh, you know, the, the pre 65
million years period where the, the,
the thing hit. They had feathers. I
wish I could, or accord at the time.
Eddie Griffin explained to me how
dinosaurs super intelligent creatures,
Eddie Griffin, he explained to me
how Bruce Lee died once. He told me,
he talks to me for like 20 minutes.
He came in the room and
there was a hundred other
motherfuckers in this room and
Bruce Lee looked at all
them bitches and said,
which one of y'all niggas wants a dot
first and then they all came at him and
they could not get close enough because
his feet and his hand was moving so fast.
These pitches was just dropping left
and right. But they had a chill day.
Had to kill him, would poison season
if I couldn't get a call to him,
he had to kill him. The poison. And I'm
sitting there listening to this call.
Oh my God.
And I'm trying to remember in my head,
I wish I knew how Bruce Lee died.
Yeah,
I could tell him cause I felt like he
died like of a drug overdose or something.
What does Bruce Lee's actual deaf. I
don't know because, hold on one second.
Bruce Lee. Firstly. Yeah. How did
he die? I thought he got murdered.
Didn't know Brandon leave at
Bruceton Brandon. We got like,
it was supposed to be a blank.
Yeah. I thought Bruce Peace
inside of it. Oh, let's see.
How did his, how did he die?
Die, Die, die, die, die.
Appreciate. I should know this
man death. Here we go. Bam.
I mean,
he collapsed in while doing dubbing work,
suffering from seizures and headaches.
He was immediately rushed to the Hong
Kong Baptist hospital where doctors his
cerebral edema. So that's
bleeding of the brain, right?
They were able to reduce swelling
through the administration of a man,
a tall whatever the fuck that is,
uh,
the same symptoms that
occurred in his first collapse.
We're later repeated on
the day of his death.
So he started having a bleeding
of the brain apparently. You know,
who knows the man that could have
been from kicks to the head. Yeah,
it's very possible. Um, he did
a lot of stunt work and the,
the reality of movies is that you
get fucked up. Brock. A, I mean,
not Brock Lesnar Bas Rutten was telling
us about how he got injured on the set
of that show lights out. Remember
he was talking about him or his arm?
His one arm that's smaller than
the other arms. We just had,
I just did a movie with him.
I just said this here come the boom movie.
So it was hanging out with him for
a couple of weeks and he had um,
surgery where they open up his nerve
canals because his nerves were compressed
and they like atrophied his muscles and
his arms stop working correctly. Yeah,
it's pretty fucking serious shit man.
This is all from just stunt work,
just doing his own stunts on this,
this TV show course and Bruce Lee was,
you know, he was doing
movies. We're dudes,
we're swinging sticks at him
and nunchucks and throwing
kicks at his head and punches.
Guess what man?
Shit's lips and things happen.
Man. Did you see that tweet?
Someone sent to us about the,
I think it was in the UK.
This woman's slapped a Dj on a bat
and killed him. She punched him. Oh,
she punched him for $5. Five
bucks. Yeah. And he died,
dropped him and in Santa Monica in front
of, Oh, a guy pushed another guy down,
killed him. He hit his head or he went
into a coma. He fell on the sidewalk.
It just went into a coma and are
trying to find the guy. My buddy,
my buddy was living on
long island and he was a,
he's a standup comic and he was a bouncer
at the time, you know, uh, it was like,
you know, for, for extra money.
And one of the guys that he worked with
just punched a guy. The guy was drunk.
I got loud, guy punched him, guy fell
back, hit his head, dead, dead. Wow,
you're in jail now. Well, your body
is fucking fragile, man. You know,
I'm amazed at all the shit that I've seen.
I've never seen anybody die in all my
years of competition and all my years of,
of, of watching UFC fights, I've
seen some close calls though, man.
We fought in a tournament once at
the bay state games in 1986. And the,
when you have no regulation,
like a sport like taekwondo,
taekwondo has very little
like local regulation.
You're allowed to have
these tournaments where you,
you have high school gymnasiums and you
fill them up with people and they're
fighting on hardwood floors and they're
kicking full blast to the face and
getting knocked the fuck out.
And people getting knocked out and falling
unconscious and slamming their head
off the ground and they have,
might have an EMT there to watch out
for you to help you when your brain is
bleeding through your ears and nose.
And um,
so we fought in this one and the
arena was a thin piece of nylon,
like a, uh, like a competition
area that they would lay out.
Their wood was marked with a square,
with a circle in the square over a frozen,
like an ice skating rink that was
thought out. So it was cement.
It was just straight cement
with a thin layer of vinyl,
which was the competition area.
So we fought on cement. Wow. Yeah.
And no one ever, someone
should've died. Someone got hurt.
I knocked the guy out and he fell
forward and he smashed his face on this
because he broke his eyebrow open.
His biggest injury was his, uh,
his eyebrow more than I kicked
him on the other side of the head.
I kicked him on his, um, uh,
kicked him with a wheel kick.
So that was his right side of his head
and he fell on his left side of his face
got fucked up. Well, you know
the thing man, where like,
there was like a certain amount of
time it took to run a mile. You know,
there is like,
I don't remember what it was,
but that time keeps getting shorter and
shorter and shorter as humans evolve
eventually because of the UFC,
some ways he's going to develop enough
punching strength to punch through
someone's face and to their brain.
That's going to fucking happen, man.
Someone's going to get the punch.
Someone's going to punch like a watermelon
right into someone's like a movie
fucking head. That's going to happen.
They're going to develop this drink.
They're going to learn the training
and it's going to happen in front of
millions of people,
and that's the end of the UFC.
Really think that's going to
happen to your hand will fuck up.
That's not what they said about the
mile. They were like, they're still,
we've gotten a lot better
at taking it to people.
Gotten not just better
at throwing punches.
They got better at taking punches too.
There's a certain amount of pounds that
it would take to punch through a human
head.
Someone knows that there's
a certain amount of pounds
and the same way there's a
certain amount of time they thought
someone could run a mile in.
Someone is going to turn someone's
head into a fucking glove on front of
millions of people.
It's going to make the worst sound
you've ever heard in your life.
We'll hear rogue and he'll
go, ah, you'll hear a scream.
Everyone will scream and this guy I'll
just be looking down and it'll look like
it's fucking fist is in a strawberry pie
face. That's going to happen
man. And then the UFC,
they're going to have to start
wearing like helmets or something.
Well that was one of the proposals
that people have proposed helmets,
super proposed, all sorts of crazy
thing. Helmets like your cycle or cycle?
The whole, well I think they were
thinking about like contact sports,
like football or football players
have to helmets. Yeah. But you know,
it's been kind of statistically proven
at least when in comparison with rugby,
which is a pretty God damn violent game
that rugby players suffer less brain
traumas and football players
do because football players,
because they're wearing those helmets,
they just feel like they can just charge
right the fuck at union and smash heads.
Whereas you know there's a real
repercussion for bone to bone contact,
head to head. But that helmet man just
gives you that feeling of protection.
But what doesn't get
protected as the brain?
The brain inside rattles around
like a fucking, like a jumping bean,
a little sack of Jello that was
attached to the walls with thin string,
you know, and then snap, snap slosh slosh.
I'm thinking how strong the brain
is that like imagine if like you,
if like you punched your hard drive,
like it would never work again.
It's like our brains get slammed
around and they still work. Yeah.
It's amazing how much trauma the
brain can take. By the way, man,
if they start making people wear
football helmets for the UFC,
it will be the funniest sport on a
planet to see guys in Speedos with the
flooring.
The weirdest looking.
Well when then someone will rupture
someone's liver with a kick and then body
armor, you know, and talking
about no tournaments.
We used to have the
where these body things.
He's like chest protectors right now
because they thought people kick too hard.
The body, it was certain kicks you still
even the chest protector on your fucked.
If so many hits me, the turning side kick
to the body with a chest protector on,
that's not good enough.
Sign up protection. Like
you hold pads for someone.
You know,
if you hold Moy Thai pads,
they're like a big thick pad and you know
you slam into them and still some guys
where they kick all,
you hold that shit for Bas Rutten
he'll kick right to that pat.
It'll fucking hurt man.
And that's a big ass thick pad.
The thing about that little ass thin
thing that they put on their body and
talking window tournament.
So if someone in a Shin kick,
like a roundhouse kick that
they would do to a tie,
pat is nothing compared to
like a spinning kick, right?
When you can spin your
body and really get that,
that fucking that torque into it,
whether it turning side kick,
it's just there's so much
power that can be developed
by martial arts techniques. It is kind of
amazing. No one's ever died. It's gonna.
Well No, I think that is
the UFC. 50 years from now,
something's going to have to change
because it's going to be people punching
through faces. People, someone's going
to kick right into someone's stomach,
Paul back and just a coil of intestines.
Just wrapped her
legs break. I've only seen one in
person live, but it was a trip, man.
It was Corey Hill. This dude is 155
pounds and he was like six one or six two.
It was really tall and skinny.
I mean he's like a beanstalk man,
like amazing aided looking and he threw
a kick and the dude check the kick and
his leg just snapped. Just like in
those videos that you see online,
you've seen a bunch of them alive.
Yeah, Dad. I never saw that growing up.
Never saw that man. I saw Moy Thai
fights. I saw kickboxing matches.
I never saw anybody break a leg.
But as soon as the internet
came along he just slept.
You know like oh it's happening. It's not
that often, but yeah, it happens, man.
I that's like one of the worst acid
trips in my life. When I was in college,
I was,
I was on acid and I'm with my friend and
I was downstairs playing ping pong with
somebody having the, it was like
going to be a star spangled trip.
You know where you can tell
where just like this is awesome.
You're feeling great. We're playing
ping pong. God, life is beautiful.
I love my friend comes down the stairs.
It's face.
Why does it ghost stumbles into the ping
pong table, knocks it down. He's like,
I broke my arm man.
And He'd been outside skateboarding and
just fell on his arm and snapped his arm.
And then that was like,
you know,
entering in a six hours of
hell is my tripping friend.
Had to go to the hospital and
get a cast put on his arm.
So he was tripping and his arm was,
well Joey Diaz is a way we're story.
I'm sure you know Joey Diaz was
tripping when he found his mom did. Uh,
yeah, I'll take a broken arm over that
every day. Especially when you 13.
Oh, I've had my arm break. I
haven't had my mom when you're 13
probably tripping for the hundredth time
to have these 13 hey, if you guys can I,
this is kind of off subject
and if you've seen it,
I don't even know if
you can play it legally,
but if you guys seen the widest kids, you
know, pledge of allegiance sketch. No.
Can we play that? Is that okay to
play it? Are we allowed to again,
because we're on Sirius now.
Ah, it's so good. God dammit.
It's get started Aaron on serious
last week. So this is probably,
we get sued or they buy insurance
and everything for that jam. Yeah,
you gotta be very careful that as that
I got a Thai massage the other day was
first massage I ever had
and it's so weird how,
how [inaudible] this stranger like climbs
up on that first they turn off all the
lights and your lay there and you're
only in your underwear and this little
Asian girl just jumps on
you came and see who she is.
She's jumping on you and just like rubbing
every part of her body against your
body. And she had her, both
of her hands down my pants,
just like go like massaging my ass
like two inch be beside my asshole.
And then there was this one point where
she had me in like this weird commerce
Sutro thing where she had to her my legs
up and like been around her and like it
was like having sex with
somebody but not having sex.
And at the end of it I wanted to fuck
this girl and I didn't even know what she
looked. Where's the parlor? Where
is this? Uh, this was just burping.
That's the only reason I didn't get
fucked. So if it was outside of Burbank,
I'm sure that I check would have like,
it sounded finished me off or
something because that was,
she was pretty close though. It was
an hour and a half of just this girl.
If you're not getting laid out there,
go get yourself a $50 Thai massage and
find it the sketchiest neighborhood.
You can man that.
That was awesome.
I wish I knew about that
when I was 18 years old.
I would be getting one of those
once a week or so. Good for you.
You should get them.
I should. I don't, but you
know what? I started lifting
weights really heavy again.
I had this guy,
Steve Maxwell,
who's is a world famous
strength and conditioning coach.
He's a friend of mine and I've worked
out with him a bunch of times and he flew
in just to work out with me
for two days and it, you know,
and he put me through two
hours of incredibly brutal
shit like yesterday and the
day before, two days in a row. Unbelief.
You feel fucking fantastic
when it's over though.
You feel like further where
you feel fucking completely
exhausted but your body,
you feel like fuck if I do this,
if I do this two or three days a week,
every week I will be a fucking
superhero. You know, he just,
cause he's got me doing all kinds of crazy
kettlebell swings and all these clean
and jerks and all the strong man shit
is crazy different fucking exercises.
But he said one of the most important
things is you need to get body work done
after you do stuff like that,
you need it. It's not a luxury,
like you got to get massages,
deep tissue,
and even that painful
shit that you don't like.
Like do you ever get like a
real sports deep tissue massage?
I don't know. I don't
think I, yeah. This took,
was standing on me at one point digging
her po like foot into my back and it
hurt like hell. Massages are
supposed to hurt a little bit.
That's how you know you're
getting a good one. He's like the,
they're digging nd you, we've mad
cute. Most of us, maybe not you,
but most people just take the
worst care of their bodies. Right.
I take pretty good care of my body,
but not as much as I should
because I use it so hard. You know?
That's why I had to take a couple of
months off of Jujitsu because of this
reoccurring back injury that I had.
I thought a thing called a rib
head that kept popping out.
So I kinda stopped lifting weights.
I stopped doing Jujitsu.
I just concentrated on just
kickboxing or two whole months.
I did very little weightlifting
like once every couple of weeks.
So we'll do it when it pops out.
Like was fucking brutally painful.
Where is it in your chest and your back?
It's in the center of my back and it
would pop out whenever I'd roll with like
really big good guys.
Like when I have a crazy sparring
session where it's, you know,
you know me and some other black belt
and it's just a attacking, attacking,
attacking, you know, and
you're moving so much in,
there's so much explosion that you,
this little thing in my back was weak
and that would be the weak link and it
would pop out and I would keep rolling
too cause I would, I knew why it was hot.
It was okay. It would hurt. I wouldn't be
able to move right for another, you know,
it would fuck me up but an hour from that
I'd be fucked. That's how
it works, man. I just, My,
my dad came to visit and I just moved
all this shit for like a bed frame and I
was like carrying the bed frame and you
always know you're going to be fucked up.
Cause there's this moment where
your back's like, hey yeah,
that you knew it doesn't really hurt you.
It's just like a spring or something
pops in your bag, something fucking shit.
Then the next day I was in agonizing pain,
but I want,
what is that window of not
well that's right. Yeah.
For the inflammation sets in the injury
sets in and then your body's going to
inflame around it to try to protect it
and that's going to tighten everything up
and emailing, Gosh. Yet.
So this fucking back injury just kept
happening over and over again. So I said,
all right,
it happened like three or four times
over the course of like three or four
months. So I said, obviously
I need to take some time off.
So I took like two whole months off
and then after that two months I just
started, uh, like lifting out, lifting
heavy again and working out hard again.
And my body is just starting to
ramp back up,
but now is the most important time
to get massage and time massage too.
And Maxwell put me through a a bunch
of different time massage stretches to
where he got on top of my
body standing on my back,
like pulling on my back while he
was pulling my wrists and stretch.
Everything's popping and stretching
it. Ah, but you need to do that man.
Amazing Body needs to be fucking you.
You body's pliable.
It needs to be manipulated
and it's malleable.
I've been trying to get
back into the gym again.
There was a time I was
running five miles a day,
which for me that's like,
it's a lot. That's a lot.
I was doing five miles a day
working out all the time.
I can't get hooked on the gym again. I
don't know what's wrong with me. I've,
I'm thinking about going to a doctor.
It's like I want to work out,
but like I can only get, you know, two
workouts in and I feel really great,
but then I just don't go back again.
So hard to get that.
Did that structure that this is very
similar to the problem with writing.
It's very similar to the
idea of resistance that
was offered up in that, uh,
Steven Pressfield's book, the war of art.
It's the same thing. It's like you're,
you've come up with excuses and reasons
to sabotage yourself and then not doing
it to resist the progress.
Were you exercising before,
during a breakup or something? No, it
wasn't like a d no, it was, uh, it was,
it was,
what was your lifestyle at that time?
That was when I was doing that
ridiculous show for fuel TV,
galaxy cabin log cabin and space.
That was where we were.
Joey Diaz played a, a guy living in
a boat that was inside your nose.
Is that what your neck now?
He was playing,
he was fishermen and so he's playing a
fisherman inside my dead grandfather.
His neck,
the fisherman,
fisherman that lived inside of the boat.
Right.
He's like an alien in the way that he
tries to attack people as he like lives in
the next,
if they're dead grandfathers and try,
their grandfather comes back and
you think it's your grandfather.
It was a really absurd, that was the
best show ever. I think it's online.
It's on the website, right?
Galaxy cabin. If you Google it,
did you have some of the weirdest ideas
running through your fucking head? Well,
yeah. I mean that's the thing though, man.
Like the trick is to let yourself
make those weird ideas and it's,
it's like really hard to
like give yourself permission
to really make the weird
shit. But sometimes I'll
see, I'll see stuff,
I'll see videos and stuff that people
do. Like a, Tim and Eric are like,
some of the people are really out on
the fringes of things and it's like,
God damn it man. You have to have such
balls to make something like that. Right?
It's so insane and so weird.
And if you try to describe it to someone,
they're there. It's not, won't even sound
funny and it might not even be funny,
but it's still, you brought this bizarre
thing out into the universe. Well,
it's because Tim and Eric
can do what they want to do.
They either on what does it fuel TV or
something like that and now they're on
adult swim. Who's watching?
You know what I'm saying?
I mean how many people were watching,
how many people are
watching what they're doing,
how many people are telling them
what to do? There's show is so weird.
You got to think that someone is letting
them be them. You know what I'm saying?
And that's why it's so fucking good.
Imagine if they had,
if they were working for center
it live and they said, listen,
I got this idea for a sketch. It's called
dance floor Dale. Have you seen dancing?
If you haven't seen dance floor
deal at leas and gentlemen,
please Google Tim and Eric's dance floor.
Dale.
It's one of the most humbling things
I've ever seen on the Internet.
It's so good and so weird and so out
there and so perfect in its weirdness.
Everything.
The guy and the girl,
it's about a guy and a girl meet on a
dance floor and they start crying. And a,
both of them are real odd
looking and they start fucking,
and it becomes crazy and psychedelic
with all these colors. And uh,
and I remember watching it
clapping after it was over alone,
alone in my office,
just clapping in front of my laptop.
Have you seen the two Terrys no.
That's something they did for
funny or die where they play. Uh,
I think we're hiring plays this,
but they play like trailer trash
or hooked on glass. Uh, and uh,
Tim has bay is fucking Eric and
it's really vulgar and disgusting,
but they give birth to a puppet
that's kind of this mystical puppet.
It's like 10 minutes and it
is the trippiest, darkest
most awesome thing. It's,
I think it's called the two
Terrys. It's so funny, but it's,
they're really man there. They
just did a movie, you know,
what is it that Tim and Eric
Million Dollar movie there?
I tell you what dance
for deal was so good.
I'm actually scared to watch their
other stuff cause I don't want to be
disappointed.
It's all good.
I mean they definitely go to these weird
creepy places like half the time you're
like, Whoa, what am I watching? But
some of that shit is very just amazing.
Brilliant. Especially at like the fake
company was the fake company that they use
throughout the Cinco. Cinco. Like any of
the product from single, the one with, uh,
it wasn't a single apple
or something like that. Uh,
the guy from growing pains,
the father who was in it,
I can't remember his name. I don't
know guy. Anyways, they're the,
they're the best man. But you know,
you watch David Lynch or like,
did you ever get to watch the antichrist?
That movie I mentioned,
you watch any of these fucking shows,
these,
these giant productions that get made and
whenever I see something that's really
vividly weird or like gummo
think of fucking Gummo.
Whenever I see a movie like that,
I always had such respect for the person
who made it because they had balls man
to like, what does Gummo Gum owes this
movie by? What's the guy's name? I,
I'll tell you the guy's name right now.
He just did an, I believe, hold on.
I'll tell you the guy's name. Gummo
is by harmony Corrine. Corrine.
And he just did a,
a little video for Diane word,
which you guys are saying that
he did this video for them,
but harmony Corrine is this
insane director who one
documentary made that never
got released his,
he was going around New York and provoking
fights with guys much bigger than him
to videotape himself getting his
ass kicked. Like he's a crazy,
crazy, crazy guy. Yeah. Check
him out in any way. Gum.
I was just this weird fucking movie
about these weird like white trash kids
living in a neighborhood.
It's awesome. But G,
G U M M O and it's a documentary.
It's not a documentary. It's a movie.
It's a movie. It's a move. So
it's not real. It's not real.
I just wanted to clearly get that
weird kid eating some in the bathtub.
This kid just sits in the bathtub and
his mom like feeds him in the bathtub.
Like, that's one of the
scenes is fucking creepy man.
She's awesome. Well it is cooled
and stuff like that can exist.
It can exist because you know the
normal Hollywood machine is not going to
approve something like that
cause it's too hard to sell.
You have to get someone who has money
in a vision in the org can talk someone
with money into like, hey, here's my
vision. What do you think? Can we do this?
Right. You know? Yeah.
When that's the thing,
when you go into a pitch and
you have a really weird idea,
all anyone at a network is going
to think is like this will never,
no one's ever gonna Watch this.
Even if in your mind you have this
pristine virgin up version of it,
it's awesome. Selling really weird
stuff is quite difficult, but when it,
whenever weird stuff makes it through,
a lot of the times it does really good.
People love it.
That's why adult swim is so popular
because there the one of the few guys that
actually let the weird
shit through and they,
they produce just nothing but weird shit.
Sometimes I'll turn on my TV and uh,
I have a projector and
there's a projector.
The projector comes down and the,
it takes like maybe 30 seconds
for the image comes on,
so I'll hear the words before I
see the image. And so it's like,
I can't do that. Why I'm part dog.
And then I'm like, what the fuck?
Oh, it's adult swim once.
Fucking weird show after the next. And if
my TV just happens to be an adult swim,
when I turn it on, it's like play the
game of what the fuck show is this?
Before I could see the image,
I can't tell what channel
it is until I see the image.
Have they played your episode of Aqua
Teen Hunger Force aqua teen hunger unit
now our special, they changed.
They changed the name.
What does that man, it's,
I got to be on this cartoon,
which is my favorite cartoon and
one of the funniest shows ever.
Like I, it's just such a hilarious
show. But yeah, I got to play a,
I'm on one of the episodes and I play,
I didn't get to read the whole script,
but I play a triangle.
I am on the episode with Neil Hamburger
plays another triangle type alien.
Um,
and I guess we're inventing these cell
phones that are basically in the future
are going to destroy mankind,
but right now they're just very
convenient and everyone kind of knows it.
So like, oh yeah, that's
fine. They're like, yes,
in a hundred years it will
devour all matter. But you
know, for now they're very,
they haven't really fast
Internet connection.
That's what I recall. It's been a while
since I did it. That is by the way,
so true. That could still be real.
That's what it was in that Kurzwell doc.
That's the thing is like these guys in
the Kurzwell doc, which is like you,
they don't just show raise
the transcendent material.
Man Kurzweil has this quite optimistic
version of reality where nanobots exist
in our bloodstream,
heal every disease and we live forever.
But then they go to these other
computer experts and when you watch it,
or initially you think they're going
to kind of refute this ridiculous idea,
but they don't refute the
idea. They're just like, well,
it is an inevitability that in the
future we will invent an artificial
intelligence.
It's more intelligent than us,
but to think that this
artificial intelligence is
going to be kind to us and not
just treat us like bugs or insects
will think of the thing is a god.
It'll look at us as these like
weird little like Mala ski insects,
like basically we're like cows and right
now we're in the process of building a
butcher.
That's the idea.
We're trying to construct
this super powerful butcher.
That's what knows everything and knows
everything. Yeah, it's really weird.
Not only that, the butcher that
can create an even better butcher,
almost instantaneous,
yeah.
Can go through 50,000 years of
progress within months. You know?
That's going to be the really nutty
thing about artificial intelligence.
It's once it's actually sent in and
you can create its own artificial
intelligence that's far
superior to anything that
we've created and I'll do that
instantaneous. Yeah, they're literally,
we would be able to harness all matter.
I mean, thinking about what they're
doing with this large hadron collider.
Simple little monkeys like you and I,
but with autism and much
more college education, they,
they've created this crazy machine.
It's 17 miles in a circle that's spinning
these atoms around a cunt hair under
the speed of light and
slamming them into each other,
making the most dense matter known to man.
I listen as humans. This is us doing
it. Imagine the kind of shit that a,
a computer that can think centi
and artificial intelligence
or are they going to even bother though
if when artificial intelligence becomes
sentient, maybe they'll just clean up
all the stupid shit that we've done.
Maybe they won't pro
progress any further at all.
Maybe logically they'll look at it and
go, what is the sense of, you know,
maybe that is a biological imperative
of human beings that we've created
intelligent life,
but that may be intelligent life won't
be under the same restrictions or
programming as we are.
And then it'll say, well,
why don't we balance this fucking
place out first? Well, we don't know.
And that's the thing.
That's what this thing's about.
It's like we really don't
know what it's gonna do,
but sometimes I think
about it and I think, oh,
maybe the way the alien comes
to earth is not an a spaceship,
but maybe the alien is outside of time.
And the way an alien
comes to the planet is it
goes into the minds via thoughts.
The denizens of the planet gives
them the inspiration to create it.
So then they all start creating the alien.
The alien comes through
the organic beings.
And then it's just some weird thing
made of metal and wires and some super
intelligence that we made.
But that's the alien. That's,
I think it's in Kurzweil's book.
He says,
the first contact we have with extra
terrestrial intelligence or intelligence
outside of humanity will be
through the roof. The machine.
It will be with a super intelligent,
uh, I don't like that word. Will,
it could be, yeah. Could be, may
have already happened. Very possible.
We've already made contact with some,
something from somewhere else or that
we're in constant contact with it,
you know, I mean, human
beings, we, you know,
we've found tribes in Brazil that are
isolated from us and we try to stay as far
back as possible. That's the, uh, that's
what they do. They try not to interfere,
you know, there, you'd find them online.
There's photographs of him and his
tribe and they're covered in red paint,
pointing arrows at a helicopter. It's
pretty trippy. Well, I mean, that's the,
the stitching stuff, you know, that's
such an Cichon Cichon Zachariah,
Zachariah Cichon just watch this
documentary on Netflix about that shit.
And it freaked me out, man.
What's it called? Ancient aliens.
Maybe it's a series on Netflix. I can't
remember the name of it, but it's like,
it's a series on the history channel.
Yeah, I watch it. But it's, it's, it's,
it's very sensationalistic though.
But just the drawings,
I mean when you look at the cave
drawings, yeah, it does look like helmet,
not cave drawings and you have to worry,
think about,
it's the Mesopotamian stuff from
Babylon and from Iraq, from Sumir.
That's the fascinating shit is
really the constellation stuff.
The really trippy shit as they have clay
tablets from 6,000 years ago that show
the solar system shows the son and shows
all the planets in their correct order
in the correct size and the correct
orbit. And it's a, it's a trip because,
you know, we didn't, well first
of all, there's an image of Pluto.
I mean if they add all those planets and
one of them was in the place where it
should be. If it was Pluto, they didn't
know about Pluto until 1930 and this,
this is 6,000 fucking years ago.
I mean this is way, way before
people were getting burned to death for
suggesting that the earth was round and
that the earth was not the center
of the universe, but rather,
you know something else.
I mean with Galileo and Copernicus and
didn't Copernicus when they subject to
house arrest for suggesting anything
other than the, the, the, the, the church,
his idea of what the universe and how
it was all structured. This is way, way,
way before that.
All the Sumerian shit.
And for those who don't know what this
says, Zechariah [inaudible] guy claimed,
he claimed that the,
uh,
the ancient Sumerian text detailed
a race from another planet,
this planet called Nibiru that came in
an elliptical orbit and it came within
Mars and Jupiter and got near
Earth every 3000, 600 years.
These people called the Annunaki,
which the literal translation is
those from heaven to earth came,
which is like very similar
to the Elohim of the Bible,
which is those who came down or giants,
you know,
people thought of them as giants and
cause all sorts of different ways of
describing them. But there's these, uh,
this crazy fucking images that they had
in these clay tablets of little monkey
people, not just black people. They say a
black person wants. And I was like, wow,
that's an alien. You know what I mean? No,
I don't know what you mean. This is the,
they all have beards and they all,
they're all look like,
like people that probably lived in that
era. They don't look like black people.
They look like a weird gods.
These weird helmets on and shit.
They're much bigger than everybody else.
And what about the skull compressions
that people did where they like tried to
stretch their heads out for
some reason? Yeah, I mean it's,
it's very,
it's obviously there's something,
something crazy was going on in that era.
You know, there was, there was a lot of,
they knew a lot of weird shit
and they knew it out of nowhere.
Like they went from 5,000 years ago.
I mean you're literally talking about
there was ego you go to like 6,000 years
to 10,000 years ago if you follow
what most archeologists believe.
They were basically
cavemen 10,000 years ago.
I mean there was no written language.
There was no, there was none of this shit.
There was no astrology, astronomy. I mean
they had all the signs of the Zodiac.
They had constellations mapped out.
They had.
I mean there is an amazing culture that
came out of nothing and there's two ways
of looking at it.
There's the way that they look at it.
The Zechariah Cichon and fans,
I believe that aliens came down and
genetically altered a lower primates,
added their DNA to monkeys or
some apelike animal and made us,
and this is a constant theme throughout,
you have fall adjusts lore and people
who are really into flying saucers and
alien invaders.
They all have this genetic
engineering theme to it,
that that is the missing link in quotes,
the difference that separates us from
from lower hominids because there's like,
there's a,
there's that giant fucking leap between
us and any of the other monkeys.
I mean, there's not, there's no
god, it's not nothing close to us.
All the other apes or nothing like us.
We were so fucking advanced in comparison
to all and we were amazed that we can
teach a chimp to spell his name for a
piece of candy. You know what I'm saying?
But you know what,
if we came into a village in some champ
was sitting there with a cell phone that
he made out of a coconut, you'd be like,
Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, whoa, Whoa, whoa.
Hold this chimp down. Hold them down and
put the, you know, trank I'm tracking.
I'm tracking them. Get them in the
cage. [inaudible] Kevin the cage.
He's making his own cell phone. He
made his own cell phone. You know,
we would freak the fuck
out if we know we had a,
a chimp to figured out how to make
his own house and built a car,
we would arrest that.
Chimp,
chimp figured out how to build his own
cars and he's out there in the forest,
you know,
with a,
he taught all these other chimps to melt
down metal and they're hitting it with
hammers and flattening it out and
building shields. We'd be like, Whoa,
what the fuck is going on? Primitive,
primitive, primitive human shit.
We would never allow in chimpanzees.
You have imagined like if chimp
started building castles, fuck that.
Exactly. But bows and arrows with chimps
had bows and arrows and started hunting.
Other chimps, we would kill
them. We would lock them up.
There's no fucking way we would let
that go down, but you know this,
this idea that that human beings at
one point in time were like that,
that we were some sort of a lower animal
like that and slowly evolved and then
rocketed ahead of everybody else.
The big question is how did that happen?
I think probably would happen.
I mean, who the fuck knows? The,
the ancient alien theory
to me is possible to me. I,
the way I look at it,
if there are humans and there are monkeys,
it's very possible. There's something as
far removed from us as we are from ants.
You know, if this, if this exists,
this, this model of the world,
if you just use your imagination and
very simple steps and think about what
we're, we're going to be, if we don't blow
ourselves up a thousand years from now,
if we do have this, this human, you know,
a technology interface a thousand
years from now and we become like super
fucking hyper advanced.
That is just as the distance
is just as far to me as us,
to some sort of an alien that comes here
from another planet and it seems like
very possible.
It also could be that human beings
have existed in this form for far,
far, far, far longer than we really true.
Then the W W we we care to believe
because the, the current like sort of, uh,
the way, uh, a straw, a
astronomers or, um, uh, excuse me,
um, uh, anthropologist when they,
when they look at, you know, the, the,
the history of this earth,
you know,
you can only go back a certain amount
of years before things are just total
guesswork, you know, and for human beings,
when you talk about like
ancient civilizations, when,
when those anthropologists sit down and
try to study clay pieces of pottery and
shit and you, you start getting into like
six and thousand and 7,000 and 8,000,
who the fuck is to say
there wasn't some incredible
shit 20,000 years before that.
If we're talking about sue mayor and
today we're talking about 6,000 years.
Okay.
What if 6,000 years before that,
there was an amazing civilization
that had existed for 50,000 years.
So much more knowledge than we have today.
But they all got fucked up by asteroids
or by shifting of the polar ice cap or
supervolcanoes artificial intelligence
that's possible. Too long made us,
and we're all actually programs.
Right.
And the artificial intelligence
eventually ran out of batteries.
Fucking died and rotted.
Gotcha. It's the old,
it's like in a Mad Max.
Beyond Thunderdome.
The kids have a record player and they
figured out how to spin it and it makes
us sound, which they like. Do you remember
that? It's like that we're just like,
you know, we're, we're
grasping at these like ancient,
we barely have an understanding of
these ancient technologies. I, I, I,
you know, I'm obviously much
less of a skeptic than you are,
but the idea that some like genetic
Johnny Appleseed style aliens that are
outside of time and space came
to this planet fucked a monkey,
put some genetics into a monkey in a
way that allowed that monkey over the
course of a certain amount of time
to build a spaceship. In other words,
the planet or a time
machine or whatever it is,
and you're going and doing this all over
the universe because for you planets or
just some kind of factories to organically
grow the super advanced machine that
we're all being compelled
to build and we don't,
many of us don't even realize it.
That makes a lot of sense to me.
It's a simple way to produce something.
It's a,
especially if you're something that's
not stuck in time the way we are,
or if your lifespan is
millions and millions of years,
then why that sounds like something
we would do. Yeah. Does sure.
If we leave all the other aliens,
say if we came to a planet,
it was filled with only monkeys and,
but we could say,
let's take one monkey and and our shit
to it and just monitor that monkey. Yeah.
And then we'll come back
after the things created.
Whatever the thing is we're working on,
you know,
when the things created the art
of super artificial intelligence,
that's when we come back.
Or maybe we don't come back at all.
It sounds like such stoner hippie talk.
But look,
if we exist and we study monkeys,
you look at all the Jane Goodall Work
and all the fucking shit that people have
done throughout history by studying
chimpanzees and gorillas and people have
been doing that shit forever. They'd
been studying lower primates for forever.
Why would we think that we're the end?
Why would we think that
something else couldn't exist?
It's far more advanced than us, just
as advanced as we are to, you know,
in comparison to fucking monkey swinging
from the trees and in Venezuela we can
be just like that.
But it is also possible that we are a
slow process of evolution that keeps
getting jacked by natural disasters.
There's a lot of evidence
for ancient society or not
interest societies or other,
but ancient cultures that
we don't understand. There's
a thing called the, uh,
anti [inaudible] mechanism.
I don't know if I'm spelling it,
I'm not saying it right, but this is
the way you spell it. It's a n, t.
I. K. Y. T. H. E. R. A.
It's an to Kethora mechanism and it's
something that was found in 1901 and it
dates back to a 150,
200 BC.
So this is before Christ supposedly.
And it is this incredible machine with
a degree of mechanical sophistication is
comparable to a 19th century Swiss clock.
And they don't know what
the fuck this thing was.
And first they thought that it was a,
they speculated that it was a designed to,
uh, maybe look at, first of
all, they thought it was a hoax.
And then when they realized it was
real, they said, well, maybe they're,
they're charting the stars
with this fucking thing.
They really don't have any idea,
but no one believed that anyone from this
date was capable of something of this
sophistication.
Like as far as like what we understand
about inventions when you're going 2000
plus fucking years ago,
people couldn't make shit like this,
but apparently they could.
There's a lot of evidence, man.
There's a lot of weird evidence
that trickles down. You know,
it shows like that. There were probably
some ancient cultures that were like,
all right,
way ahead of where we thought there.
I believe that the most out of everything,
yeah,
that seems to be more likely
than the alien thing or that we,
where are we crashed here like a friend,
like we were from Mars.
There's a lot of people on the ship and
people that believe that that Earth was,
uh,
only a inhabited with lower animals and
lower primates and that Mars was the
more sophisticated planet. And
then, you know, Mars there,
they're absolutely convinced.
Now Mars had life and Mars had water,
a lot of water flowing water and that
something happened to Mars and Mars lost
its atmosphere. Whether it got hit
by a media, which is very possible.
And you know,
that's where all these fucking people
like Richard Hoagland tweak out about all
these weird shapes on the surface
of Mars and try to say, yeah,
we'll do no faces. They tried to say
that this is a pyramid and this is a,
you know, this is a dye condor.
He drew structure and you know,
Tetra Hydro and they try to like make
all these weird connections between one
rock to another rock and
they use mathematics and say,
this is very similar within one
degree of the, you know, the math,
the way the layout of the great sphinxes
and the Pyramids of Giza. You know,
so who the fuck knows? But you
know, the thing is it's like,
look at the alternative
thing to believe in.
You've got the idea that aliens
came inseminated the planet.
We're descendants of something from
another planet or the more popular theory,
a bolt of lightning hit a plasmatic.
See what the fuck is that? Now that sounds
crazier than both of those theories.
But wait a minute.
It's not,
because what you're saying that the
aliens always existed and then that they
didn't, no one made them
out of a bolt. Enlightening.
I mean where the fuck did it
all comes down at Wyatt Bolt.
The lightening got thrown in.
That's why not look, it's a,
it's a can of something happened.
Oh it's like a fucking lick up a storm.
A storm caused some shit.
You know that electricity somehow or
interacted with amino acids and created
some little fucking Amoeba.
I'll tell you this,
if I pause and choose between hanging
out with Penn and teller are you,
I'll take you any day of the
week, man. Penn's a great guy.
You'd like hanging out with them and
the whole fucking like I'm sure Penn and
teller. I'm sure Penn is great,
but I'm saying like that version,
that current religion, that current idea
of things is so dry and boring to me.
What do you,
when you're saying that current,
like what do you exactly do you mean?
I'm saying like the skip dice,
cynical rationalist view of how life
came into onto this planet c is,
so if nothing else,
super boring,
it's the most boring a
bolt of lightning hit, uh,
hit some carbon and cause it
to, is it Darrell man? To me,
that Shit's not boring at all.
That's so fascinating.
The idea that that can happen and that
it is an inevitable process that happens
just with nature. If that's what
we're creates it, if it's, you know,
amino acids or water or whatever,
it gets in contact with some force.
I mean that's amazing to me that I
don't think there's anything dry or dull
about that fact that that eventually
becomes consciousness to me is just,
it's just higher order life from single
cell to multicell to this thing that we
are now, which is some sort
of an adolescent stage of
evolution between, you know,
a conscious,
a universal being and monkey
fuck monkey like Arnold a uh,
fuck monkey. You know, Arnold is like,
he's like the epitome of the, the,
the, the transition. No Man wants to be
the governor and he's still a fuck monkey.
Just shoot loads and has made,
what if he,
what if he just Jerome about him
every night now. It never stopped.
I haven't as giant. I go back
to fleet. Joe, remember him?
His balls.
I remember like this guy is just taking
his underwear off in front of everybody.
How fucking crazy it was.
It was one of the strangest
dreams I've ever had in my life,
but it was so vivid and it's because of
these nootropics. I'm taking a guarantee.
You Chrissa Marcus who's
doing them with me.
He told me one of the weird side effects
of these things. You have crazy as well.
We're going to get him. It'll be
where we are. We're filling out the,
we're finishing our paperwork and
everything where the testimonies,
I want to get tested.
I'll get you some,
I'll get you some right after the podcast.
We'll,
we'll call him and we'll have them
shipped over. But um, all right,
so that's the end of the podcast.
Listen folks,
we were sorry we took the two weeks off,
but we enjoyed the fuck out
of coming back and we're very,
very happy that we stayed in the top 10
of iTunes the entire time we were off,
which is amazing.
I,
I'm honored that you guys
are a downloading it and
telling your friends and all
that good shit.
We got a lot of cool shit coming up.
We've got a lot of things in
the works. Click gas. Yeah.
Cliffy be tried to reschedule to another.
He wanted to move to Friday.
I can't do Friday.
I want to be in Vancouver.
I think that's going to be Tuesdays me
a special edition at like 10:00 AM what
we're going to do.
Either way.
We've got a lot of other stuff
coming on too and we uh, we,
I can't tell you about some things,
but we'll be back next week.
Um,
I'm not sure with WHO,
but most likely next week it'll be Monday
and Tuesday and I'm getting together
with Kevin Smith next week two and we're
going to blaze and do a podcast at his
place. Just me and him. So
I'm looking forward to that.
That's going to be fun as fuck. And I'll
let you guys know about all that shit.
Sounds comedy. Hold tonight. We've got
a show tonight at [inaudible] hall.
If you're in La, come on down
because it's a, what is it,
like 15 bucks or something like that.
Like that. Yeah. Links on your Twitter,
my Twitter south, the whole.com.
Yeah.
And there's a lot of people that are
going to be on who's on the show tonight.
Ah, we got our magical
uh, Tony Hinchcliffe. Uh,
Jason [inaudible]. Um, his girlfriend,
Danielle and uh, I think I'm
forgetting somebody, but yeah,
it's going to be good show. Yeah, those
are very funny comedy. What are you doing?
You wrong? Nah, I can't
do it tonight. Fuck Bro.
He's allergic to hanging out with us.
I'm not allergic and using us for
the podcast. That's cool man. Yeah,
that's what it is.
Um,
so the other dates that we have coming
up July 1st is the big one at Mandalay
bay. That's a Joe Diaz, me and Ari,
and I think Doug Benson is going
to do a guest spot too. And uh,
tickets just went on sale for that.
If you go to Joe rogan.net,
you can find the links and all that shit.
It's all up there, right? So it's a,
that's at the Mandalay Bay
theater. Um, and also, uh,
Pittsburgh on June 25th,
there's a UFC down there on the 26th.
So I'm doing the Carnegie
Music Hall on the 25th.
And that's what Joey Diaz as well.
And that's a June 25th in Pittsburgh.
So tonight,
if you're around, if you're in Hollywood,
come on down. It's 15 bucks. It's fun.
It's a cool little intimate room.
And we've got a lot of funny people
and we're going to have a good time.
So that Sal's comedy hall, and we do
that intermittently whenever I'm in town.
So that's like a,
it's a good spot to come and hang
out and just support live comedy and,
and we fuck around and come up with some
new shit. Um, thanks to the flashlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on
the link on the right hand side for the
fleshlight and enter in the code
name Rogan. They give you 15% off.
Remember on sex toy from apple?
Alright,
that's it. Love you guys. Thank
you very much for tuning in.
We appreciate the fuck out of here.
Please follow Dunkin and check out his
podcast that he does with his love of the
young lady, the lavender hour,
and that is available on iTunes.
And also check out the desk squad.
That is Brian red bands,
little sort of studio thing he's got
going on and got a bunch of cool podcast
with a bunch of funny comics.
Our right bitches,
CNN to see you.
Hm.